[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
maybe not the smartest decision that we
will find out
first of all let's do some roll calling
to build this and around what's going on
I see a lot of y'all in there already
Joe Mack is going on Salute yo G
Christopher Hart oh hell no doubt don't
tell the Don and talk with snitching
hands and okay necro events as hell what
up I am Mike what's going on I declare a
thumb war he said IOP is greater than
the NFL what greater than the NFL or we
have arrived we have arrived no doubt
Luther
my bad loot hero what's going on yeah
King about to go off allegedly
THX what's up Mr ordinary Zach Riley
hustle hustle and motivate what's going
on DMV how my level sound how we doing
I'm back I had a podcast wait a minute
okay Asanti the legendary
my man black conflict X let's go let's
go Isaac Gentry what's up you already
know Zach Kareem what's going on thank
you thank you Russell I appreciate you
brother thank you thank you yeah man off
the cobwebs try to do this podcasting
thing it's been a minute we got some
super interesting topics you already
know what it is the Lords will be here
in full effect we'll talk about it you
know what I mean maybe some special
situations and surprises Tim the
sorcerer
oh yeah that's true them
[Music]
it's gonna be some fun
I will be back Julio rules what's up you
know yeah we'll just saw him up in here
and oh shout out to the Donna Taco
remember for 16 months Lord Silva
Splatoon 3 just blew out every premium
shooter in years strong campaign
multiplayer with good content and
progression monthly updates and no micro
transactions I don't know about the
to play
people are gonna graduate
I will say this though
and that's the tool did you see the part
about video where this is cool they
opened it up for the public
and they started cheering and running
towards the station
I was like that's different I go for a
Nintendo energy it's different how she
says addicts just kind of low yeah I
think he's stepping away
ducky what's going on Kings fall in the
building you already know I mean my
means in them to move to last night but
anyway
will be back we will get disaster
dominance we will try to find the king
make sure the king is good we want to
hear what he got to say clearly and I'll
see y'all
[Music]
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rains you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you man
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the flame still I'll be
running collecting them rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start it
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you that's
[Music]
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold y'all
I ain't heard the boy and you ain't
gotta say it I'm embarrassed for you I
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Voltron with and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when he was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
and we are alive I Am Lord podcast Lord
Cognito here talking about the latest
with Advanced GG there's a lot of things
going on with the new product live let's
get right to it
so we got that Focus line y'all this is
that standard that's what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
game in we don't use coffee anymore
we're utilizing this focus on debt
number two you already know it's my
favorite right here the energy line you
already know birthday cake one of my
absolute favorites completely delicious
this is a pre-workout equivalent and
also doesn't use beta Adeline so you
don't get the Jitters and stuff like
that so it's really good for that and
then the new new we got that hydration
line y'all this is really good for
people who don't like caffeine who want
an electrolyte substitute and it is
really sugar-free absolutely delicious
so you got your three choices once again
you know Cog love is sour you already
know and we're doing this right now so
go get yourself to advancedg.com use
code iron Lord on a checkout this is
something I use all the time got to
support Advanced EG great products if
you want to get your workout on even if
you don't work out you're just gaming
you need that focus and again the
hydration in line for those who don't
want caffeine no sugar electrolytes
you're good to go lower Cognito here
iron Lord podcast peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
like check bike check where is officials
that's that's official hey this is
despite itself okay oh my God that's so
crazy apparently he's got like a like a
negative 700 favor right now
I'm about to just I'm Logan
about them at the house anyway Anderson
gonna win but part of me feels like if
pardon me feels like Anderson is oh
right yeah
part of me just like man always matters
you other dudes
they see they see that that how they
gonna say no kids yo y'all foul see hold
on let me get Lydia master
um himanshu yeah they want to see us
see we see the truth now we see
gymnasts
bro we the Jackson Five like we the
other is Michael is not here yeah with
Tito with the rest anyway
here you hear you and we are live
welcome to the incomplete Islands
podcast LFC and the Lord's again to
Kings podcast
welcome to kicking them
overdudes.net episode number 271. it's
another Glory Sunday we're back at the
round table of the Lord's date and today
we've got Sony calling Xbox Call of Duty
offer
inadequate Marvel d23 and Ubisoft Ford I
do miss King laughing when I say topics
he like though
cyberpunk Edge Runner update and PS5 he
knows not to come in here hard like this
oh no he definitely coming or not yeah
no I'm talking about with his music and
stuff oh he's better now we're gonna get
demonetized
PS5 redesign and Hardware Chief to
discuss so we go get right into it so
let's introduce the minus one four
horsemen of gaming those original gaming
Knights of the realm here at the round
table my co-host with the co-host my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf
mommy Lord addict how we doing sir
he's
doing no I was I was reminding King not
to come in here with music
last thing we need is a copyright strike
that we can't stream I agree uh doing
pretty good man uh you know I actually
did the king's falling raid like five
times this week like I did a lot this
week yeah I did it with some lfg people
uh what's funny is when I'm in because I
don't talk about you know who I am on
log stuff but what's funny is when
you're doing lfg and P and they talking
about people you know like Cactus HD
didn't teach it right there like he
should have done the video better and
I'm like I'll talk to Cactus
that's what's up you still getting you
know oh my God it's not an addict it's
him no you know what's funny I I've had
that a few times in multiple scenarios
once I had that playing like a Game Pass
game uh then I had that playing demons
uh not demons so um
Eldon ring once I was I was helping
people on lfg and I got a message from
someone on elegy after I helped it and
they put it on Twitter and said Lord
addict just helped me beat the uh uh a
boss on Eldon ring he was definitely uh
a weird scenario it's got like you can't
really prepare yourself for that like
you think you can but it still catches
me off guard to this day especially
we'll go like packs each or something
it's weird then like yeah no absolutely
absolutely it's cool to see the Cedar
Grove game wise it's been that just been
at the uh Kings fall on that's pretty
much it
yeah right now I am going to be doing an
interview on the 14th the 15th uh It
Won't Be Live uh I I do I will announce
that so I will be doing that interview
so we'll go through with that uh we
actually do have a a lot of stuff in
store for you guys so you know we saw
how many of you guys like the the twitch
straight of the uh the community stream
we had last week uh King's not here to
defend himself so
I just my team destroyed King's team
during the King Street man you know all
right let me let me lay it out the way
it happened for you guys you know we've
been down like 15.
hey you know I'm sitting there I'm being
the leader I am please
and I'm sitting there and I've seen
don't give them ground you take an inch
and they'll take a mile give them no
ground
it was it was a fun time man it's a fun
time absolutely then then my dumb self
ran it back and lost
okay
salute man hug each she's confident on
that we'll get to the super chats in a
minute and of course
returning of most technical gaming Lord
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player's selfish experience and proudly
is our softstradamus the Lord of clarity
Lord Patriot of the iron bank my man
Lord Sovereign returns I'll be doing sir
and sleeping better out
well hello this is my voice now from now
on this is what happens when you have a
surgery on your esophagus this is what's
good could be yourself
don't don't see him
respectful respectfully respect respect
maybe I sound like Mrs doubts
listen Downton Abbey how are you doing
I am I am good
I'm not I'm not good I'm I'm getting
there
I could talk now last time you guys
talked to me I sounded like I was two
seconds away from the gray yeah
but I'm good voices getting stronger I
still feel kind of like congested and
stuff like that and that's going to take
a while to to be a hundred percent but
uh I'm good I'm feeling good looking
good sir thank you very much you get a
chance to anything you've been playing
it or it's just been recovery how's it
been and the week that I had off for
Recovery I was like yes I'm gonna play
I'm gonna do now I was miserable I was I
was in pain I was like fevered up so I
didn't get to do too much to like the
tail end of it
um and last weekend a little bit so uh
unfortunately I wasted six hours of my
life to uh the new Saints Row that was
oh Jesus oh no it's not not good not
good yeah you think that we should have
civil lawsuit and get you that six hours
yeah man I I need to get those back
because that was imagine if they had to
give you life back that you didn't like
giving them like it's like they had to
push a button and like refresh six hours
of your life I'd live yeah I'd get
another 20 years back I think for all
the stuff that I played that sucks
probably went through it you went
through it so um yeah that was not fun
they I don't know what the hell they did
with that game but it go back and play
Saints Row the Third and Saints Row four
you'll be fine even Saints Row Two on a
360 is kind of better which is crazy
um that what else it just kind of uh not
too much steam deck because I was home
so I was like on my consoles right so I
haven't done too much of that
um what the hell else did I play I got
to watch some stuff like I I watched a
little bit of She-Hulk and
um I watched Pinocchio yesterday with
wifey sat down to watch it with wifey
the the new live action and that was
cool just to see that old you know movie
it was a live action
just going straight to Disney plus and I
was like okay of course it was pretty
good Tom Hanks playing Geppetto and it
was it was all right they changed some
things you know modernized it you know
you just you can see the discourse
online oh when you say modernize it okay
okay there's discourse about that
because of course about The Little
Mermaid yeah you know discourse
discourse
yes yes I saw that I saw the beginning
of House of dragons I still I gotta
catch up there again and it's a good
show that's probably what I'm gonna do
right are you feeling it because I gotta
figure out I mean after that first
episode it's right where I hoped it
would be so I think man three was good
yeah I'm sitting here I'm watching these
episodes and I'm like can I forgive them
for Game of Thrones yet I need a little
bit more time I need a little bit more
time they hurt they hurt my feelings at
the end of that but um yeah and then I
haven't watched rings of power yet so I
want to watch that
and of course the Incredible Hulk of
this hopefully will be joining us in
progress so y'all could still listening
access game
[Laughter]
oh that's mrs.com
but of course we still have the gaming
ninja itself the Shinobi Lord Cognito
spread that we listen to the rubbing IOP
not telling what you want to hear what
you need to hear shout out to my brother
Mr Maddie Pace who still has not played
who's it like a dragon let's keep the
pressure on his neck keep it on his neck
y'all I did everything I was going to do
he didn't play um Yakuza like a dragon I
did his dangan Romper I did all that I
gave him the synapses you know what I'm
saying or nap so he got to fulfill his
and and the ball game keep the pressure
on him but we had a great episode
talking about obviously sure suicide
King in the chat sauce
what Stand Out Suicide Kings ooh for you
why they saying that you guys
Mega episode crossover episode Chris Ray
Gun the Dukes and Ainsley from season
gaming so listen to that
oh what's that oh man yeah I got y'all
went in
yeah
we had to have some real talk you know
what I'm saying but it was good man we
try to get some balance and get some
other perspectives as well so salute to
that and then um yeah shout out to the
last word came back to that you want
this time guy Travis the homeless shout
out to seph Roth from the IOP uh Clan
man he was on he was all suited up it
was all cool talking about what's going
on and that's you know that good stuff
under or lap and then I'm back I'm back
for packs Pax West in the building man
first off I'll be remiss if I do not
salute the best cameraman in the game
Sorry Pete I love you
but oh my bad Bill Stillwell the
legendary epic games holding it down
holding me down I was out there dolo he
was just like yo you know if you want a
rock let me know I was like yeah
absolutely and we just tag team you know
what I'm saying we came through you know
what I'm saying and just really covered
these games um I want to shout out to a
lot of people who have all I get to stop
by and chill right now oh
oh first of all forget about me is
Michael is here
the Jackson 4 they're done now anyway
and of course yo bro you got a whole
segment of people like yo where's King
where were here what you talking about
so we gotta introduce wow Incredible
Hulk of this aka the access gamer there
we go louder
the prophet of Xbox
the king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
be love it Lord King with the crispy
beard
today we was stream and my bed was
looking tatted
excited salt and pepper a little salt
and pepper salt and pepper I had to go
to Mount Olympus talk to Zeus
turn that volume up
my volume don't get levels up bruh oh
hold on hold on
it sounds fine to me yeah okay okay I
just want to make sure
yeah you're talking you talking real
soft that's what it is yeah yeah I'm
sorry man I apologize this has been one
crazy week and it's like down the crunch
time and we got inspection coming oh and
it's I'm like remember I painted the
whole house yeah we paint in the kitchen
we uh have to have a list of stuff that
we have to do so we're doing those
things and I gotta I'm going to this
place buying rails to put outside you
know oh okay all types of crazy it's the
craziest thing ever but um down the
crunch time I'm gonna give us a shout
out to
Galveston okay and his son okay because
on Thursday I was having a really really
bad day right and um
he logged in and he was like hey you
want to play some fortnite and I was
like yeah cool so you know he's
the way he views me is not like how I
view myself
right so I view myself as a as a game
player like you know nothing special not
for real yeah King's still low see
that's I know what I know the chat hello
yeah you low you low turn turn your your
window volume up or something you know
what I'm saying because your joint is a
little low I knew it wasn't me
and I might be a little bit low because
all the stuff that I was doing going
through but he said um
he said you know my son always wanted to
play with a YouTuber I don't consider
myself a YouTuber right right so uh we
played fortnite and the sun jumped in
and he was like yo you're a celebrity to
me I'm like oh I I just I just play
games like and you know we we talk about
it we hang out with the homies
and he's like no
he said you know like you know how you
see uh your favorite baseball player or
something like that he said you that for
me
and I was like wow that's crazy and I
was at I was at a I was at a low point
and um so we we played
and we wind up getting you know the
chicken dinner we wind up getting that
win and I had to pull it out you know
for for him and his son did that and
then um the next day we played again and
you know we won again
um but
I just I just want to tell people like
sometimes you could feel down yes in
somebody else's perception of you can
lift you up so it's not always as bad as
it seems and it's not always as good as
it looks you know so a lot of times you
know people think you on cloud nine
everything is fantastic and it don't
really be that way factual so you know
um I always try to greet people with a
smile and I'm never too big to play
games with Excuse me my peoples I feel
that
that's real that's real yeah that's all
I've been playing this week and uh some
God some some God of War type game that
was inside uh Game Pass you remember my
name it's like something killer gods or
something like that
this is the like the the yeah I'll just
jumping off I did my show already but
I'll just jumping off into Pax West
again salute the legendary Bill still
well for holding me down doing some
starts getting hashtag team with the
coverage that was dope um just want to
give a couple of shout outs to people I
got a chance to meet in person the
legendary Jason Ronald was so cool you
know what I'm saying to kind of chop it
up with him shout out to um who else man
Paris Ferris Lockhart you know what I'm
saying Major Nelson rules Malik Prince
Philip Prince was really cool Khalif for
that work
um the blonde nerd awesome obviously Co
East Windward and gameplay was there and
Reggie
the reginated Bronx is in the building
man got a chance to talk you know what
I'm saying his time was time was limited
but uh we got chance to build a little
bit you know I mean so that was let's
see what the bill on that one but um
yeah it was cool and then obviously I
want to shout out um like I said a
couple of games that uh when it's you
know as far as standouts that I cross
paths with me personally probably my
personal game of the show was last case
of Benedict Fox I really that really
surprised me I didn't think it had
combat elements the way it did you know
what I'm saying it was really impressive
I always give me orivage but the game
looks really impressive
um also gun grave Gore that looked
impressive I didn't know that was an
anime that's giving me devil made Cry
Vibes that looks sick no place for
bravery 2D uh kind of pixel art style
but just over the top very gory and then
like um a Parry system that see really
cool with the actual which I really like
um Planet Alana looked amazing gave me
another world Vibes you got just a
little companion she's walking around
shout out the Xbox on that doing that
matter anomalies was another one jrpg
joint with a kind of cell shade look
really cool King The Joint for you
yeah my friendly neighborhood
is literally survival horror with the
Muppets
when you sat down with the dude and he
was like yo it used to be a muppet place
and he laughed he do the creepy laugh
and he said um and then it was abandoned
Marcus was still there
broadcasting I was like yo that's creepy
as hell yeah shout out also if y'all was
in the building I got a shout out aeolia
this game completely hands off first of
y'all like hands-free adventure oh man
really cool like it he had like great
music probably problem solving you're
doing all this stuff with the elements
like you're doing like conducting Powers
you got super powers and you in this
space this world and it's really cool
man that's out there I want to give a
shout out to you what's up I want to
give a shout out to you
thank you it's it's it's it's kind of
crazy because we all you know as a team
as a unit
we had various different things going on
at the time that you grabbed the
gauntlet and went to packs right you
know we we all wanted to go to Pax West
yeah I mean that's like on a bucket list
for all of us right but um you know
solve
had you know the surgery yeah you know
attic had some stuff going on with his
stuff
and I have stuff going on with my stuff
and I mean like you showed it a load
like and then to see all the interviews
and all all the meet and greets and you
doing all of that and I'm sitting there
like man my my bro was over there he he
he's he's tearing it up so I hit up a
couple of people in the background I was
like yo thank you for looking out for my
brother Wally yeah yeah appreciate it
appreciate it you know what I'm saying
man thank you
I got a great team I've learned from
from great greater people and then
obviously you know you guys always hold
me down with stuff like that and just
trying to be a fish obviously I can't I
am it is not the same experience without
the Bros you know say without the
regiment it's not the same I just try to
my mindset would just say condense it
try to focus on what we can because
there's a beauty in King got everything
he gonna do you understand it that I got
attic on the side you know say he could
do the game play because the only thing
that hurt I felt was like I wanted like
the gameplay a little bit more but then
that was they were kind of I said look
if y'all could play that'd be better
because I just want people to see the
game at its best when I don't have the
difficult game Cocker doing his thing
and then you know what I'm saying
Breaking the game down and letting me
know and then saw off you know with the
smooth interviews and we do our tag team
analytical joint you know what I'm
saying that you do his solo drink so
it's it's like a shout out to Toby he
wanted to say hi to y'all like he he
sold tremendous love there was a Dev
that didn't know us and there was I
don't know they're interviewing you
you're gonna have a fantastic time I was
like okay Deb's coming up from 2017 2018
like yo you guys covered my game and now
here's our new game I was like yeah like
it's just it's a thing you know say like
yeah man but like Pax West was dope like
PAX East is still going to be the home
team but I have to admit kid like Pax
West is that and look kind of booty yes
very premium very I think you're gonna
fit it well it's very you know very
fluent very very absolutely absolutely
yes at any minute you can you know walk
past on that booty oh there's already
like it's just a thing you know what I'm
saying like yeah so go check that out
and um yeah
[Laughter]
anyway moving on so yeah as far as that
definitely kicks for Ray finally done
King was in the chat that time we
started it
um finally with divinity I know that's a
big controversy to chat right now but we
got it done with divinity it was Luke
shout out to the clan shout out to ducky
DJ all Rose who else did scream Sinister
you had a Wild Bunch yeah it was a while
it was a wild Cruise
yeah it was dope it was dope no doubt in
their first games uh just started
cyberpunk and I'll tell you why we're
getting to that
um what else so I've been playing Tekken
seven like crazy on Steam deck for some
reason that's become my go-to game where
Steve Nick looks phenomenal yeah
trying trying to embarrass me
[Laughter]
not one match but I won some rounds but
when the last time I played Tekken but
I'm gonna say God bless it's all good
it's okay so look man um before I was
gonna get into this scribe song before
we get the super chats
okay cool man let's get down okay
even with Cedric H member for two years
thank you brother I appreciate that we
got the Liz 22 member for 20 months
Laura bronze it's 104 p.m and your
experiment of not starting at 1 11 A.M
on football Sunday needs to be
re-examined
listen started yeah it started it
started you know listen man oh wow
that's crazy that's crazy
I figured it would be that much
opposition if I kept things the same so
for people yeah even for even for me
like you know what I'm good let me sleep
let me sleep and then you don't look
yeah
you were like I quit another guy you're
literally I'd have been under the gun
yeah
respect you know there's a lot of things
going on our schedules rest and then
also I want to respect my brothers and
season game and I got love for those
guys they moved over you know and um
old time but I remember me and had a
good conversation about that maybe a
year ago you know he said oh y'all go
yeah he didn't know that we used to go
at 11. I was like yeah we do that for
football I was like don't worry about it
it's all good so yeah salute it up man
shout out to subscribe to the channel
too but anyway you can have both things
on at the same time it's fine you don't
have to make people choose yeah exactly
remember the Xbox used to have that
split screen thing yeah
Xbox snap the TV TV TV
anyway and we got yeah baby
y'all
to the King show and some other guys
this is what word this is
thank you brother appreciate it thank
you
I'll get to New once again five dollar
Super Chat playing Halo with addict and
King last week was fire need to play
more of that Dead game hope you enjoyed
it as well despite the stupid issues
yeah it'll salute to you okay I gotta I
gotta play but hit me up one time it was
late but I gotta I gotta play with you
on that other Halo man for sure
right
foreign
[Applause]
he or she I should say
yes correct they wanted to get a contact
then we have
pull it before 14 months big
big up to the crew
School Bella ring knife
then we got yeah baby father I want to
get two dollar Super Chat let the truck
the trucking's arrival yeah we need to
get some trumpets for kids he needed
like a serenade or something like yeah
[Laughter]
uh I'm gonna be coughing throughout this
today
we got free R Kelly box outside he
outside there show your face today
where's where's Tex I have to meet text
I have a video every text yet
Oh you mean you mean uh Buck but oh it's
Buck Wow
over Halo died why you ain't playing
Halo Microsoft killed that old Flagship
titled Jim Ryan drinking your t's in his
Martini or tears and tears if it's teas
but tears and his Martini apparently he
wasn't
um part of the group that was playing
Halo with the team uh since you're here
regularly I suggest you go and get a
little man or a series X so you can have
games to play other than Twitter
[Laughter]
then we got um himanshu yada with the 40
rupee Super Chat King Canelo was Triple
G prediction any chance for Triple G I
don't think so he has a huge chance for
Triple G really oh okay all right so
there's three different injuries that
Canelo was working with right now he's
working with the injury of his shoulder
if you ever see him have that tape on
the shoulder on the shoulder he has
suffered with torn labrums so right now
arthritis is setting into the shoulder
also has a bad knee he doesn't do too
much road work so if you notice Canelo
doesn't move around the ring as much as
he used to so and he also has the tape
on his knee so I'm pretty much assuming
that arthritis is either working his way
into his knee as well these dudes can't
keep training and doing the stuff that
he's doing
at the same time Triple G wasn't
fighting the same times Canelo was
fighting so he's pretty much on the
Shelf so if he does have one good last
fight in him this could be that one good
last fight and remember power is the
last thing to go on every fighter okay
next up Sir them got Lord Metroid member
for 12 months shout out to Cog for the
excellent packs West coverage thank you
sir thank you Cod is too big of an IP to
keep exclusive Money Talks good to see
saw back thank you brother appreciate it
I don't believe that what you're saying
we will get into it and then we got sin
Vendetta five dollars
as a homie right there King when you
said a God of War type game I thought
you were about to drop a name drop
Dante's Inferno love that game
yeah I think I think that's the name of
it it's so much fun you get a group of
like five to six people and you're going
to dungeons but only one can go in at a
time and it's like permadeath so if that
dude goes in there and he dies you lose
him but if he comes out with the stuff
you know your groups get to partake in
what he came out with it's dope no doubt
what else you got then we got free R
Kelly two dollar Super Chat gang I can
get you into packs okay you can get
yourself out of jail
yo how you gonna get me into packs and
you can't get over here
don't do it
yo
all right there we go hargit so they
went to get 20 Super Chat Jim crying
dance moves lion Ryan needs to show us
the adequate offer that he made to fill
when he married the ex Bungie so we can
all see what he's looking for I mean he
obviously sent one right right
wow Bungie told him from the rip we for
the streets
pay what you will nowhere for the
students
no no then we got free R Kelly again two
dollars every money
Halo dead at Microsoft Bungie made the
right move oh my God I don't care how
much you're yelling from the rooftop it
don't change the fact that we all was
playing and you was looking over the
wall
no dude I'm like oh they still having
fun
still like that anyway yeah well uh the
man who got them horns remember for 27
bucks much love to the crew the Ubisoft
event Was Made watchable thank you King
addict Mega and kid welcome back south
thank you sir hashtag moving powder oh
yeah
send off and focus up y'all Focus like
too
um addict wanted to do the stream so um
you know I'm down I'm down with my guy
at all times no doubt no doubt continue
then we got we got resting Craig face
first PS snitch into the FTC and now Jim
Ryan snitching on Twitter it's gonna be
a good show oh yeah it's gonna be a good
show because imagine we got some friends
that have arrived the people we haven't
seen it oh my goodness got some really
cool guests man let's start off with the
legendary ACG angry said Target gaming
How We Do excerpt good thanks for
inviting me what's up brother good
looking good been a minute it's been a
minute man everything all right
otherwise in the gaming world for you
yeah for sure for sure interesting
interesting couple weeks yes a lot to
talk about and of course it's been a
while you know what I'm saying but the
inseparate one except it goes one of our
hovies of the Xbox expansion pass how we
doing sir
ah so good man back to back to being uh
healthy again good to see you guys and
uh glad to see everybody good to see it
thanks for having me on no doubt no
doubt turn up a little bit yo we gotta
hear a little bit of that that ghost
talk you know just a little bit are you
good to go okay okay perfect yeah yeah
there we go there we go there we go
that's the ghost I know what we got uh
we got two more Super chats Luke uh
fantastic interview with Sheamus yes
fantastic yes yes good good job good job
no doubt go on a second let me get thank
you so much
let me see what we have Simon Brady five
pound Super Chat can't wait for King to
lay into crying right
Ryan's interview sounded like he was
with his therapist the entitled attitude
of Sony is embarrassing we need to get
to the top again we get to the top again
we have one other one oh that was it
that was very cool and I do have to do
something real quick before we start the
show every you know what time of the
month it is that log that that Lords of
gaming.net y'all again salute to the
entire team tremendous team of writers
editorials been great they've been
absolutely killing it with the coverage
when I was out there at Pax West
um it's been really cool to see you know
and I definitely want a salute in the
environment that we're creating for you
know people who are trying to get their
start in the industry freelancing things
of that nature man salute to the team
this is a war being dizzy thought about
and kind of rewarding people you know
for their work so first to the team
salute to everybody amazing job I love
what you guys are doing second you know
is now it's that time you know we got to
celebrate a particular scribe who kind
of went above and beyond beyond in the
month of August his kids have been
killing it man he's been killing it he's
been absolutely killing it with the
fighting Community Evo stuff Destiny
seasonal coverage he's been doing Marvel
pop culture one of our most consistent
Lord's minute series King with no so we
proudly present the latest winner of the
Lord dizzy log that scribe of the month
to Ty Swinson AKA Prince delos salute
you already know again he couldn't be
here to accept his award shout out to Ty
yeah my road dog that's my buddy in arms
and on behalf of him I will tell you
that it's been a long road and um you
might not have to do anything on
bathroom because he left something for
us oh hello there oh he did also known
as Prince delos I'm so grateful to
accept the award for scribe of the month
once again for lordsgaming.net my time
as a writer here has been amazing and
just spectacular working in the games
industry for the first time
throughout my busy schedule I love that
the team and Laura cogg understand and
allow me to take the time to write about
things that I am truly passionate about
as well as doing the Lord's minute
recordings weekly with Lord King getting
to talk about the newest Marvel Star
Wars or hit TV shows there it has been
such an amazing experience and King is
so knowledgeable about everything it is
crazy we can just be talking about one
thing and King will just pull out
another knowledge that I had even no
idea about so for the viewers at home
who are watching Laura's minutes on the
weekly thank you so much I'm learning
almost as much as you are on a weekly
basis
soft addict King and Cog you all make
such spectacular content weekly with
Iron Horse podcast each and every one of
you are an inspiration and I just want
to thank you on behalf and the bottom of
my heart for everything that you do for
the realm and the gaming industry as a
whole
now for the viewers in the realm if you
haven't checked out Lord's mini yet
April and soft also do amazing content
on the weekly you are missing out if
there are things that you want the panel
at the round table to cover we might be
covering here at Lord's minute again
right now King and I are doing She-Hulk
on a weekly basis right here that we'll
be hitting up whatever the next newest
thing is d23 just has some amazing
announcements Mandalorian season three
Ahsoka the Star Wars Tales these are
things like King and I will definitely
be hitting with our Lord's minutes so
make sure you come and check us out
we're here every Monday Wednesday Friday
at Lords of gaming.net again thank you
so much for having me as a
writerlordsgiving.net thank you round
for supporting the podcast for
supporting the last minutes and for
supporting all the writings for all my
destiny fans out there I see you I
salute you for checking out my writings
people in the fine game Community I see
you I have a passion for fighting games
and I'm doing whenever whenever I have
free time to cover it as much as
possible and here at Lords of gaming
we're also gonna be diving to the
Esports scenes so just be there check us
out we're only going to be getting
bigger and brighter every single one of
the writers and editors are spectacular
they are heroes in their own right I'm
just super happy to be a part of the
team
once again thank you all so much I hope
you have a great rest of the day enjoy
the show
this has been Ty
peace out
we're hot hot bikes are hot it's shout
out to time man salute man brother
salute only award you've been killing it
salute to the whole team again but I did
the scrap of the month log shout out to
Ty uh Ty let me know what you need uh
immediately so that you'll get it by the
end of the year thank you
[Laughter]
I'm looking for something I thought I
would have that today to do some stuff
Teespring yeah
real quick before we move on shout out
to shout out to Lord Macho for trying to
not walk
thank you thank you yeah yo he looks so
debonairs
shout out to you and your wife
congratulations yes nobody ever looks at
the groom at the wedding you know it's
really not about you but he definitely
he did that
I got to say that yeah he did that so we
good on that no poll because last week
we miss so we're going to get right into
these topics and let's talk about
anything for me
real quick one more Super Chat uh we got
real member for 10 months PlayStation
six PlayStation 6 turning into Sega
their games going into PC and switch
like portable or cell phone games where
is the new God of War trailer okay all
right look at that there's the thoughts
I want more stitched remember for 34
months let the king read the good word
from the book of X hashtag stop
stitching hashtag Sony ain't getting
caught oh my God anyway so let's get
into it man look so it's a big hot one
this this week we all know um yeah shout
out to gamesindustry.biz Playstation
Xbox Call of Duty offer because uh was
inadequate considered adequate on many
levels by Jim Bryant so um looks like
again this the disagreement that's been
going on with we do chronological order
you know obviously Phil Spencer came out
there to talk about you know providing
the um signing agreement to Sony to
guarantee Call of Duty on Playstation
with feature and content parody for at
least several more years and then um
basically the current deal between Sony
Activision Blizzard around Call of Duty
is believed to cover the next three
releases including this year's Call of
Duty Modern Warfare 2. however so he
feels that it's uh offer doesn't
consider the impact of PlayStation
Gamers going to Jim Ryan I hadn't
intended to comment on what I understood
to be a private business decision but I
feel the need to set the record straight
because Phil Spencer brought this into
the public forum Microsoft has only
offered Call of Duty to remain on
PlayStation for three years after the
current agreement between Activision and
it's only ends after almost 20 years of
Call of Duty on Playstation their
proposal was inadequate on many levels
and failed to take account of the impact
on our Gamers we want to guarantee
PlayStation Gamers continue to have the
highest quality Call of Duty experience
and Microsoft proposal undermines this
principle so this hit the waves I want
to roll my eyes every time I hear that
really do like I want to literally yank
my eyeballs all roll them back to the
back of my head and put them back in So
this definitely tore up the internet
this was a big one um before I start
because I know the realm usually likes
to have me ass kick for king would you
like to go first or would you like to
when you get the option I need to I need
to address the stench in the room oh my
God I need to address the snitch in the
room why is it snitching what's cool
though why the boss gotta come out
snitching and writing like he off rip
like it's at a point y'all guys got to
stop repping this dude like y'all really
gotta stop repping that whole Squad you
out here putting up your dual sense no
you need to have sense because
um it's out of control where I come from
that snitching stuff ain't cool you're
gonna sit there and try to preface it
like Phil told first like shut up Bill
ain't say nothing he said that yo it's
gonna be at the end of the contract
we're gonna throw that out there for
three years that's not not good enough
he could have just told you no you don't
get nothing into the contract he don't
owe you anything okay he don't care
about your fan base so at what point in
time is he supposed to care about do you
care about me where's that Final Fantasy
at bro yeah that's why I roll my eyes
because it's like man like I I have to
buy a PlayStation for a lot of ips like
okay sorry good too this
this he talks out of both sides of his
mouth while you looking right at him oh
and it's out of control he did the stuff
with Bungie I had to wait a whole year
to get a hawk Moon
yeah exclusive content I had to sit back
and wait
but it's okay it's okay it's two years
on this side they extended it remember
it was two years ago in a year they kept
they kept doing things it kept poking
the bed
and Phil Dominus Maximus are really
expensive not having it no more
so you're fearful right now that is the
most fair-lading uh text that I've ever
seen in my life oh it's not adequate
nobody owes you a damn thing bruh
so at what point in time are you going
to look over to your fan base and
actually do right by your fan base
70 games raising the price on a console
that already is in existence oh you're
doing practices that are anti-consumable
but you're screaming out who's looking
out for you you ain't even looking out
for your fan base oh
so you're gonna talk about this guy over
here that's all he ever does is look out
for his fan base and his fan base wants
Call of Duty for dolo if you ask every
Xbox dude this don't give them a damn
thing
let them let them stall Popeyes biscuits
for you
biscuits no chicken just the best dry
biscuit man yeah
man no you know no churches churches you
know with the honey on top I like that
biscuits you take five Papa biscuits
that right there is a torture tactic
but I I say this to say let's go Phil
has always been benevolent
always trying to reach across the line
yo listen man
you know after 2024 we know that your
joint is up
it slides you that for three years
you got that grace period
it ain't gonna be no PlayStation six
let's be real kid he's like we're gonna
slide this team for three extra years
you got three extra years to find a
solution like you you can't make a game
within that period of time you got five
years to do this you can't come up with
what what what's up with so calm you say
you have no faith in your developers at
any point in time and every time I turn
around this dude keeps constantly doing
things to talk about uh FTC uh filling
them
might not let that come over here you
know I'm afraid this is anti-competitive
all your whole practices have been
anti-competitive
so at why why does this have to come out
and all you PlayStation dudes out here
repping this dude I cannot stand behind
a rat
and he's he looks like oh God
he's I'm not a crook you also a crook
sir and you're doing crook like behavior
and you're trying to point over to the
dude that is actually a little angel
talking about he's doing bad things to
me he poked me come on man we're not
gonna do that here and I hope I hope I
hope Phil looks at it and say you know
what 2024
it's a wrap oh you gonna like the polls
oh he gonna tell him to deal that that's
what we do we tearing up the deal I hope
because it is sick and tired of you back
biting and talking stuff in the streets
snitching you gotta you got a whole
1-800 number did you see 1-800 number
I've never seen a anything like this but
it's games you can see that business
what 800 number that's what we're doing
but listen
nobody cared when you brought bungee
nobody cares sir you saying they might
be entitled to a loss
instead of 1-800 number wow something is
happening
and this is the first time
we're seeing up that skirt like we're
seeing the knees knocking the ghost face
was like wow you know what we're seeing
we're seeing knees knocking they're
whistling past the graveyard right now
they sound like Mike Tyson you ain't got
nothing coming they they are terrified
and when this deal does go down and it
does get inside Game Pass
you have nothing to offer from your own
words from your own mouth your
developers can't come up with anything
within five years that can compete with
Call of Duty
so just pack it up Don't Bring Out
PlayStation checks
thank you King for your thoughts and how
you feel about this situation let's get
uh Steve guys I want to start with ACG
it's been a minute ACG man you know
obviously this the news broke all over
the place I mean it's going crazy
there's a lot of thoughts you know now
that you got a couple days to kind of
let that marinate let it resonate what
are your thoughts about your Brian's
statement in the whole Call of Duty
offer
uh
that the offer itself original when you
look at the way he talks I always like
to listen to
the the entire way he puts together any
sentence that he's talking about and how
much he tries to frame a fact within a
soft fact and then look at the soft fact
and see what he's not what what he
really doesn't want to talk about so the
first thing he stated if you if you like
study that psychology of people a lot of
people like to crouch there are soft
ideas within a fact and so everything
sounds scientific so the first thing he
said was here's the amount of years now
ignoring the oh Phil said something so
I'm going to say something [ __ ] he's
already talked multiple times on Twitter
about all of the exclusive stuff so
that's uh that's sort of I would say
sort of swimming in the same sea of
Twitter just having a 24-hour lifespan
for most attention spans because if you
do go back and look you can see he's
done this so that that was a little bit
like you know two school girls poking
each other but when you look at what he
stated he stated something that was very
interesting to me he said it was three
years but it was inadequate on multiple
levels so first of all I want to say I
don't give
a crap about the three years okay now
because he stated that with a number
scientific thing he can't argue math he
stated three what I want to know now and
what I want people to break down is the
inadequacy on all levels and call him on
that and say all right let's look at the
inadequacy on all levels and see really
what you're trying to say versus what
you're actually saying out about because
the inadequacy on all levels means much
more to me than the three gotcha because
a lot of times people say oh he hit me
and then he also did some other stuff
and you're like well okay we know the
hit part let's look at the other stuff
and find out if he's if he's completely
lying one thing to remember about Sony
is Sony has gone out of their way to
make sure and attempt to get exclusives
including star field that's not a rumor
that's a fact they did attempt to do
that so they've attempted to do these
things I do understand when they look at
Activision and they see a massive
company they're a little bit nervous
Sony was the number one you know red
winner for Activision or Activision was
the number one Breadwinner for Sony when
it came to the platforms they were doing
very very well with Sony but I think Jim
did something really intelligent I'm
going to give him a Kudo probably not
probably a a slap and then a pat on the
pat on the back with this the Kudo is
that he did a very smart thing when it
comes to PR he's drawing criticism
towards the deal
by stating the inadequate on multiple
levels right when everybody's looking at
these other situations
and I I want to make sure people
understand one man just put a wrench in
a 69 billion dollar deal by stating what
he said even if he stated it on his
slate-like camera that looks like it's
from 1904. it doesn't matter the dude
the dude it doesn't matter it's the one
smart thing he did was he immediately
put a bunch of criticism out there and
we already know when you look at some of
the decisions that have been made in the
ideas of if if Sony is going to stop or
if anybody's going to stop this
Activision deal there's a lot of really
weird comments about like well we don't
know how Sony's gonna deal with
Microsoft and you're like well who cares
like that's sort of the way you have to
deal with things you have to live with
the competition especially when Sony for
the longest amount of time did the most
underhanded things known to man I have
friends who worked at companies first
for Sony and the stories they've told me
have been dire on some of the stuff that
they pulled so you do know that they
they do this they do what everybody else
has done what this really is is I mean
not to bring up current events but when
you look at the political spectrum of
people 10 years later telling on
somebody who did something 10 years ago
what's finally happening is the people
who used to live under umbrellas with
Sony are starting to feel a little less
tense and they're starting to talk about
the things that they've experienced
things that a lot of people who leave
the industry will talk about but they're
not going to want to talk about it when
they were the 800 pound gorilla but
they're not anymore I want to you know
just for a quick second because again
you don't have to get into specific
because clearly you have a lot of
relationships I don't want you to blow
that up but the the the theme of you
you're saying like of people maybe let's
say limiting fear but a concern based on
being under that umbrella you know is it
is it is it more about just the way that
they've been treated or just practices I
just want to kind of like a general idea
of what that feeling and thought process
if you can the original idea was
especially the stuff we know for sure
happened which would be like back in the
PlayStation two one days especially with
the Sega Saturn Sony would buy companies
and shudder them because they didn't
want the game on the Saturn now that's
something that's known it's something
that has a history there's no you can't
argue that it's like an argue and
gravity when it comes to the Future and
we're looking at the way people are now
what's happening is
they used to be everything
and so what would happen is that's the
deal you made and this is something that
happens to rock stars and rappers the
deals you make or with the major
Publishers right once smaller Publishers
came about they were like hey you know I
can sort of say what I want to say not
that they're right because people just
because you're a Indie person doesn't
mean you're telling the truth right but
you can get a little bit more data out
there what's happening now what I'm
hearing is that Sony is sort of
mistook what was going to happen this
time and what's happened is people are
starting to see Game Pass starting to
see Microsoft as a legitimate competitor
even more so than three 360 days because
the developers I talk to are higher on
it now than they were with the 360. even
though the 360 outsold the PS3 many
months in the United States it did very
well but there is a huge positive like
idea about where Microsoft is going with
streaming I mean people are like dude I
can put it on one system and have it on
Windows I have it on you know and I'm
not saying they're right or wrong I'm
just saying that they're starting to
come out and starting to say you know
what we don't like the practices by the
way the same thing happened to Microsoft
I want to point this out Microsoft got a
ton of crap when the Microsoft games
division basically just absolutely
cratered a couple times it's taken 10
years now for them to rebuild themselves
yeah and remember when arcade came there
were people you know really complaining
Indie developers like oh yeah doesn't
even answer our emails yes oh yes
generation especially yeah it was
ridiculous really bad yeah I just have
to say that's com that is something that
is not just pointing on Sony these
companies do it Nintendo does it and
then the last thing is these guys most
likely what we will see this is just my
personal opinion is that if the deal
goes through
um what we'll see is that a deal will
change with Bungie and you'll see
exclusivity there
yeah
I still think that's what's happening
so wait what do I see so you feel it I
don't know this is how they exit this is
exit
all they have to do is see if that's the
way you want to play that's the way
we'll play by the way if you don't
believe me look at what Microsoft stated
when they did buy obsidian and look in
Bethesda look at the stories where they
were like we know Sony was out there
trying to get exclusive and what happens
is once somebody does something somebody
does something else and it's a cold war
or the hot War it depends on how it's
going to go but if I were Sony if I were
Sony as a businessman it has nothing to
do with if I like Bungie I would
immediately look at my exclusives and be
like I agree
and and I don't see any argument against
that people will say money but what will
happen is Sony will say
the exclusivity of our platform is going
to be worth more to us than putting it
on Microsoft system whether that's true
or not I don't know but they'll flip the
bill Microsoft bill so your general
consensus is that from a reaction to the
standpoint if it goes through expect the
intensity or aggressiveness with
exclusive deals and exclusive content to
try to lock more to their platform as a
result if it goes through well yeah
because Sony's full of crap when they
pretend they don't do a ton of exclusive
stuff and so what Sony will do is Sony
will be like oh that was yesterday they
wait 24 hours for Twitter to forget what
they're talking about they're like nah
nah look at Microsoft but if you look at
the massive list of ubisoft's exclusive
stuff if you look at the massive list
they're they're a huge number of things
and I I personally feel that Jim it
certainly comes across as a businessman
who knows that he needs to make a
decision and if this pops up he'll just
do it and just be like we'll worry about
it later even if it's one of your
exclusive which it sounds like for
Dustin or destiny you guys already we
have well yeah well the thing is in that
deal though Bungie was explicit in that
they were like we were not doing the
deal and even we had Hogue law and he
said contractually he's never seen a
deal like that where Bungie pretty much
remains retains their um multi-platform
status but it's interesting to see it
where and you can buy yourself out of
any contract no I do how do we know that
because Bungie no longer is owned by
Microsoft yes yes well I stand by that
is I don't feel like Bungie can be
bullied but I feel like Bungie could be
corrupted by Sony in the long run where
you know once you putting that money
through there
if you threaten to cut that that nozzle
off like I feel like some people on the
higher end of bunch you'd be like look
like we've been doing this for five
years of Sony they want Destiny 3 or
whatever to be exclusive like like we
gotta kind of do it or we're just we're
gonna have to go be an independent
developer you're like let's not forget
that Bungie has I got you've been with
major corporations a couple times and
then celebrated when they've left them
they celebrated when they left Microsoft
they celebrated when they left out dude
can't get along with anybody exactly
no I agree I agree my pushback was just
that historically that they they they
don't like being controlled and being
told what to do when they fought for
that position but
um I will say yes so the I will say
because of the way it was set up the
deal was set up was very interesting to
me the way they fought and I've
surprised that Sony even agreed to it
but we have to see it I want to get King
because Kate has his hand up he was
patient
yeah we all know Bungie for the streets
moment that y'all sit there and say oh
you can't go and do this and you can't
go and do that I don't care who you own
and I got a ton of lawyers that's gonna
get me out of this because I signed the
prenup way before that so if you think
I'm not gonna be partaking over there
you're out of your mind and they as soon
as they say you can't go over there they
lock the door and I I agree with you
King but what my perspective is not now
here now it's the future
it's it's it's the current people that
sign this deal are all retired and
they've and they've passed their mantle
to other people I don't think so because
people can be corrupted but I don't
agree because if the next thing that
they're building is them trying to go
even bigger than Destiny 2 and make it
be an even more immersive game that that
requires community no I and to them that
matters more I think than the bad
especially I love you guys and your
optimism no you're wrong and I love you
ACG but I think you're wrong
optimism
I'm talking about live service
engagement it is not advantageous to
lock down a live service game to one
platform
you're absolutely right but I I I have
including Call of Duty which is what
they're doing you guys are not
understanding this is where we're
splitting into to a cold war between
these companies and there will be a time
where I have to decide that but let's
talk about something else that we know
has happened in this house 100 which is
that Sony purposely didn't put
development team time on some games that
they owned or had partaken of a third
party both systems were getting it so
one system didn't have as good a
performance or whatever just done the
same thing so welcome to Destiny where
it doesn't run very well you talk about
here's something more important
you just you just explained to me why I
do believe they will try something along
these lines they want a service game Jim
Ryan has stated we have 12 service games
all you're going to be doing on the Sony
PlayStation with our first parties
playing I'm just joking
today service games are are huge and
service games allow for them and they
cost a lot of money yeah right but I
will tell you these companies have
enough money that they could quite
easily build something into a service
game that is exclusive for their
platform that makes it almost no I'm
talking 100 useful
we got to get girls we could go back
this is a fun way the ghost
expensive has to hold me what's up
what's going on sir it's been a minute
so now that this is shaking up Twitter
shaking up everything on social media
Tim Ryan went was trending you know I
mean the words and the words inadequate
I've seen use in so many different
contexts
and stuff it goes how we feeling man now
that the news is resonated what's your
thought process
so I agree with Carrick and that that
absolutely without a doubt there is Jim
Ryan's doing what he's supposed to do
he's casting out doubt on a deal he's
putting that seed in people's minds
hoping that it grows into something
special to disrupt the deal and that's
what he's supposed to do so Props to him
for for successfully doing that uh on a
couple levels where I get hung up with
with Jim Ryan because without a doubt
PlayStation has earned some leeway right
they've been putting out incredible
first party catalog they've earned some
leeway
the bangers indeed and like don't do it
and I'm I'm stoked for uh for for
Ragnarok right I'm stoked for the next
Spider-Man game like there's a lot there
but the problem is when you add all the
little things together that Jim Ryan's
policies have done I'm surprised people
are still willing to go to bat with him
and I'm talking like 70 games versus 60.
not a big deal games are expensive
that's that's a small thing but then you
couple that with the the debauchery that
came with uh the horizons forbidden West
upgrades remember that yeah that didn't
feel very broken platform raising the
prices exactly yeah you're ahead of me I
got a list here
you got the Horizon thing then you have
the discussions about things being
inadequate as far as what it's meant to
PlayStation Gamers well what did what
does that mean when as far as Xbox
Gamers and Street Fighter for so long
right then you've got final face then
you've got uh the fact that they were
trying to shop out Starfield they were
trying to keep that exclusive prior to
the the deal then you look at the way
they uh refused to let Spider-Man exist
on other platforms and I don't mean the
PS4 Spider-Man like insomniacs I mean
like Spider-Man in Avengers couldn't
exist you know what I mean like little
stuff that seems so anti-consumer uh all
the exclusivity deals that came with Cod
and then to the to the point ACG is
making like they're choosing to price
hike their system at a time where
there's worldwide recession and it's the
right time for them to do it on a
business sense because they're still
selling out and they've got God of War
on the horizon but none of it feels very
pro-consumer and so to suggest that
somehow Microsoft's being anti-consumer
and we're the painting themselves you
know painting themselves the heroic ones
just felt very flat very Petty the way
that uh I don't have the Panache that
that King has as well very disingenuous
but like to call Phil Spencer out like
that in a world of gaming three years is
an eternity it's an eternity beyond the
original deal and to my way of thinking
like you're lucky you're getting that
but also Microsoft's smart to not take a
live service game and limit where they
can do it if they want to play a cold
war you know come June 2023 when uh
provided the deal goes through
Microsoft's holding a lot a lot in their
Arsenal uh to to negotiate with to
battle with to do whatever needs to be
done in a cold or hot war and it seems
odd that uh this is the the angle that
Jim Ryan and Playstation would play yeah
um I get it I understand it but it's
like Yo dude you better hope that the
Microsoft doesn't suit up because if
they want to come they're going to come
for real and it's it surprised me a
little bit yeah yeah no it's it's very
interesting goes uh which year there was
it was surprising to see the public
nature of this right right exactly these
are the kind of conversations generally
you're not because the Public's not
privy to so that's why it's just so
crazy right so yes it's a lot to um okay
well so we got some insight thanks to
the Brazilian laws that allow different
deals under scrutiny allowing to be seen
we've got insight into things that a
Brazilian wax version of deals yeah
exactly yeah
when you have no other recourse but the
shout
because it seems like it's not going in
your favor and it doesn't bode well but
this is a guy who doesn't you know from
his own mission doesn't play video games
but he's in the head of the video game
department of uh
he is the money man the question is will
it come back and bite them all these
small things again 70 games not a big
deal but will it come back you know the
price cycle I would argue that it
already has though yeah Luke when you
look I think especially the price hike
like they got a lot of flack for that
well King has been preaching this he's
been preaching when are we going to
start paying attention this generation
to all the little things right that add
up and he even got me well the little
mentioned too with the original Xbox
when they were pretending they didn't
want to do DRM as well
works with companies is all it was smart
Sony nailey but they were like okay here
just put in the game and you're like wow
that was huge a lot of this stuff
I hate the country because you all five
remember that day me a kid remember like
it was yesterday was the E3 historically
Microsoft goes first kind of in the
morning and then delay it and they
delayed that conference one hour when we
see the news come out later after fact
people go yeah they were like oh once we
heard that you know we you see
engineering can we do that can we remove
the camera and the DRM and then we've
got ourselves in a ninth position
it's like Microsoft and Sony both came
together and okay this is how we're
gonna go out there and then Microsoft
went out there and they ship and well
okay go get rid of that get rid of it
they don't like that he pushes you
forward you know or when they're in the
scary house pictures and
amazing interview by Ryan McCafferty on
IGN yeah those are easily the best aside
from your guyses of course I gotta say
the Kings but it's easily the best
interview and Jack Trenton really
actually explained a lot but didn't say
a lot listen to his interview and you're
like oh wow there's a lot of weird crap
sorry
leadership in charge it was different
leadership in charge of Microsoft to
Fumble the ball the way they did he's no
longer around and there's different
leadership in charge right now and I
believe if you had the Old Guard uh you
wouldn't got the price hike in in any
regard
um you would have got uh for that a
couple of things that is traditional to
the uh how PlayStation handles their
business we're not going to say that in
that they're not a company their company
and they're supposed to go get money but
this seems egregious a lot of stuff
seems just egregious and they put it in
the face of the consumer but trying to
act like you know
um we're up against it and I don't like
that it comes across as disingenuous and
some some people and I know you say when
are they going to stand up
sometimes you dig yourself so deep in a
hole
you don't know when to get out
right you you don't back this dude for
so long you don't know when to get out I
saw signs anyway so I just walked away a
long time ago but I don't like
what they're trying to portray okay yeah
I'll see what you go I got to get attic
human patients sorry now you got you're
good this is a spicy one attic man now
that the news has resonated
inadequacy is the word is the deal
inadequate
I just read that quote again
read the beginning part because it's
it's a spicy word he just said um he
said it I hadn't intended to comment on
what I understood to be a private
business discussion so it's almost like
so it's always like you stop talking
it's like you can just feel it
you know he he saw the opening
you know what I wasn't going to talk
about it but since your man out since
you brought it up since he outside with
him I feel the need to set the record
straight because Phil Spencer brought
this into the public forum Microsoft has
only offered Call of Duty to remain on
PlayStation for three years after the
current agreement between Activision and
Sony ants after almost after 20 years
the Call of Duty or Playstation their
proposal was in the adequate on many
levels failed to take into account of
the impact on our Gamers we want to
guarantee right there right right there
I hate that
that one sentence makes me want to just
reach across the screen like what are
you talking about it's like if he would
have Chuck just took that one part like
first off you can't stand not here
screaming for your Gamers and screaming
for Microsoft to care about the the
PlayStation consumer base well you ain't
done nothing for the Xbox and consumer
base if anything you have prevented Xbox
from from promoting Destiny to their
player base you have went out there and
Stripped Away multiple exclusive IPS
from score Enix you tried to do it with
Starfield you did it with a bunch of
other Bethesda games and you will come
here and say but Xbox don't care about
our consumer base because you don't care
about theirs I can't even talk about
death Loop all right can you talk about
death Loop right now oh yeah that's
right
to Lord attic that's the first time
where I've seen his ire that was pretty
well done wow
is the energy yeah I was just like
sitting back going God damn man oh this
life feels act that's a light fast yes
I've missed them
well technically maybe a chance and this
time
punching people oh yeah that's at it oh
yeah he on it I just I just don't
understand
how this man's that's the audacity to go
out there and say that he he wants Xbox
to care about their Gamers it's like
that's why I put on Twitter I said the
moment Final Fantasy and not to mention
this is the amen that made that that set
up a deal to get exclusive content to
this new uh Harry Potter game and then
he goes out probably in the same week
and say yo I don't like the fact that we
ain't getting Call of Duty potentially
in three years it's like dude shut up
like I don't even want to hear him talk
anymore it's like I have never really
remotely been on that standpoint it's
like you do it you do it for business
but when you come out there and you try
to make it a soap opera that's when I
have an issue with it it's like if you
would have came out there and said yo I
would prefer if we have a a more of a
conversation I don't like the agreements
that we're having I don't know where
Call of Duty is going to be for the for
the PlayStation brand in the next three
to five years I would like to have more
of a conversation about that and just
kept it at that but then he comes out
there and be like Xbox don't care about
our Gamers and I just I just personally
feel like we we're being left out right
now like we have done we have done
nothing but be right to you guys and you
guys are coming out here and you're
doing this to us and I'm like
like and
that Final Fantasy 7 keeps getting like
teased with us
she's like hi how you saying here and
lock an entire Trilogy down and come
here and complain about college dude to
your point not even teased we saw the
language on some of the um marketing
material as far as the deal from Final
Fantasy 7 remake be ending at a specific
time so Xbox fans did get their hopes up
that it eventually come go she's gonna
jump in real quick and not get back
well I just think all the more evident
look at how Microsoft has stewarded
franchises like Minecraft they've got a
proven track record of being willing to
publish in parity on competitive
platform or competitors platforms and
still this is an issue and a concern and
it just seems so odd to say for Jim Ryan
to spout off as though it's not going to
be respected when they're willing to do
it and we talk about live service games
it doesn't behoove Microsoft to to pull
Call of Duty away uh that early into the
deal and three years how many things
happen in three years that is a long
time I feel like that's that's being
missed by some people because in the
world of gaming in World War look at
Microsoft in 2017 to 2020. like as how
many more Studios how many more games on
the horizon and then you look from 2020
to 2023 like how much is different three
years is a long time
I'm just curious
if this was the other way around would
he be and have the same energy I don't
think he would I think he I think they
would have already came out to yes I'm
applying they would already came out and
now it's Call of Duty exclusive
PlayStation I'm 100 announcing that
because it's just like why is it that
when Microsoft does something they're
expected to play safe play with others
play nice but when PlayStation does
something they're like that's just a
logical why are you doing that Xbox nah
man at this point after this whack
um
what are we doing no I'm not yeah I'm
ripping I'm ripping the deal and you
know what we just stand it up
over here looking at this like I'm being
petty at this point
I'm like second looking real nice on our
stuff right now I'm looking over there
right now that's like you guys want to
play the top exclusive stuff we gonna
play the by the publisher and yank your
stuff off your stuff
to me the only difference between this
and Microsoft is Microsoft has the money
to buy the building and Sony does it so
they have to do these timed exclusive
stuff isn't it funny how they said
Microsoft needed to compete
now that Microsoft is competing you're
like oh wait a second not that hard
you can't you can't see I've been saying
this for years they take them and
they're going to drown them in deep
Waters that they can't follow it yeah
and and this is them this is them
exercising see Microsoft finally
realizes
that for them to win they have to kill a
fly with an atom bomb
and this is and they're finally
realizing that they have the means to do
this and utilizing that fact why not the
funny thing to me is it goes back to
what ACG said about
um you know what was inadequate right
when you look at Phil's exact quote Phil
Spencer's exact quote in January we
provided a signed agreement to Sony to
guarantee call of duty duty on
Playstation with feature and content
parity for at least several more years
beyond the current Sony contract an
offer that goes well beyond typical
gaming industry agreements and and a
deal that we can assume ends in 2024 or
something like that right so an
additional three years makes it 2027.
like everybody's been saying we don't
know where Call of Duty is going to be
in it by 2027. it could be on a download
it could be even bigger nothing that
they can compete this is all posturing
because Jim Ryan I gotta admit your mind
is a good business man he's about the
money it's a business part he's not good
at the Optics part but he's fantastic at
the business part yes so he's just
posturing because if he can help it and
and knock this deal down
like why not character said like he said
you said a little something get a little
more eyes scrutiny
I think that's the biggest issue I have
it's just like his his regards to
wanting Microsoft to care about their
consumers when they have it the other
way right but his job is to be a
hypocrite that's the job that I mean
that's what their job is right he has to
go out there and same way Phil Spencer
would have to go out there and rebut
this right so the thing about it is that
this thing's a little out of pocket
though like something that he wouldn't
normally do to speak on things
of the situation it is
I will give him this I will give him
this he has thrown out all he's thrown
out the the entire idea that he has to
put a face up to to look strong he's
decided that in this instance looking
weak and looking attacked is a better
strategy
because he he's he's not possible I care
about the pr Optics of this because he
does not let's keep it a box
completely a hundred percent so to me
this shows the reality is that they are
scared of this of the possibility of it
but at the same time A smart business
would tell you take that deal and
obviously reassess it in 2027 because
you know Microsoft is going to want to
reassess it if Microsoft the only way
they don't reassess this is if
Microsoft's plans for Call of Duty
within the next five years is a it does
it's not annualized anymore and it
becomes a different Beast right it may
and from a money perspective maybe that
doesn't make sense but maybe they have
different plans maybe they different
Call of Duty products that aren't FPS
Shooters right because if you think
about it cut makes millions upon
millions of dollars every single year
but it also takes hundreds of millions
of dollars to make a game
that is effectively only alive for a
year until the next iteration comes out
right so it's it's kind of wasteful at
the same time right I can see Microsoft
trying to figure out a different way to
do it right I can figure that out right
also in five years the expectation is
that the proliferation of Game Pass is
going to be so widespread that perhaps
they don't need Sony anymore at that
point right so that is another thing
but that's the thing right
the business of the changes so like like
go said the business of it changes so
quickly
that it it behooves both companies not
to get into bed for 10 years it doesn't
make any sense right so Jim is full of
is full of it he's posturing as much as
he can but he's decided to posture from
a weak position to see how that looks
and optically to the people that are are
looking at the stuff and have to make
decisions about this stuff maybe that
looks good because I'm gonna be honest
with you I think both of these companies
understand that these Regulators don't
understand gaming
but the thing that the thing so what you
have to do is appeal to them in a way
that makes sense stuff trading on
Twitter right they understand that
because they all they came in and
commented on that that was crazy the
comment on something on Twitter
um but the thing about it is is they
they out there and they're going to do
he's gonna say what sounds best in terms
of okay this is this is not good for the
consumer right the same way Phil is
doing right and he's seeing how that
works at the end of the day I'm gonna
tell you this whatever he's doing the
monkey wrench is trying to throw into it
it isn't working because check this out
the fact that Phil can talk about giving
them an agreement means that you can't
you can't talk about this stuff before
right when you do when you when you when
it wasn't ready to go you could not talk
about it right all of a sudden now he
can talk about it like they're
essentially the deal is essentially
Devil's Advocates it was implying that
Phil wasn't supposed to talk about that
if it goes by what what Jim said that
Phil spoke first right he spoke first
about Jim said if Phil says January now
what's funny about this it gives a
little a little insight onto deals
period right
back when they were initially asked
about this Call of Duty stuff right if
it was like no we can't we can't we
haven't talked to them because we can't
talk yeah sure that is true that is true
am I saying that as of January of this
year which is nine months ago
they were able to give them a kind of a
agreement in writing as to what they
intended to do with Call of Duty uh
franchise that supposedly don't control
yet at that point so uh the deal is done
I don't really see what this gets you
from Jim Ryan except trying to use that
weak position to look like hey this is
something that needs to be looked at
twice
but I don't think that's going to happen
I think the deal is done I think he's
gonna take that extra three years and
everyone's going to reassess in 2027.
and you know it is proof that Microsoft
rights to take it away if they feel like
again Game Pass and whatever else
they're doing in their ecosystem is
large enough and has a wide enough
breath that they don't need PlayStation
but again make no mistake that these are
all little moves to try to squeeze the
PlayStation I always say that I feel
like Phil it isn't aggressive because
he's just such a nice guy but all the
moves that happen these very nice guy
moves it's real gangster moves the real
gangsters
my apologies
you had some thoughts sorry for making
me uh I think everybody actually covered
what I was going to say I do want to say
that um that for sure Microsoft's uh the
the one thing that they did that I got
to give them kudos for that even I
didn't necessarily agree with was the
Xbox series s and um and then Cloud so
people are not really content this is
one of the reasons why I'm I'm still in
disagreement with everybody here
thinking that there won't be some stuff
with Call of Duty and and some
exclusivity going on and one of the
reasons why is because
um Xbox
really in the old days everybody was
swimming in the same pool with the
little swimming dividers and everybody
was in the same race Microsoft switched
the pool and it's a little longer and
it's filled with their games yeah and
the weird thing that's happening now is
that in the old days you used to say oh
well they don't have third-party games
that used to be a thing because Sony
always had third party you know they
always had these titles out on their
PlayStation systems now they're all on
on Xbox and I think that the big thing
that's going on right now is that
Microsoft's also looking at the cloud as
a way if you guys noticed when you
watched um these last two events Disney
and and Ubisoft there was the occasional
mention of cloud this game might be on
the cloud blah blah I do not at all see
a future where Call of Duty isn't in the
cloud whether you want to play it or not
you know what's funny I'm so glad you
said that ACG because the thing that I
always thought was interesting was that
the the the beginning that the time this
deal was announced and the Microsoft
representative that made the public
statement
the statement
the thing that I always thought was
interesting being a kid was like
he mentioned Nintendo switch you know we
want to get this on other platforms and
I'm with you AC to be that screams Cloud
because we already know they've been
doing stuff 505 games they ain't trying
to control they've been playing around
with streaming you know from higher
Fidelity games that wouldn't necessarily
run on the switch natively right into it
and like you said we we talked about um
mobile we talked about you know
obviously the Activision Blizzard King
The King aspect of the deal Microsoft is
really deficient in that space shuttle
to UK you made that part it didn't
happen what's your name so um you know
that's interesting so I'm with you that
there is plans I think to take Cod way
bigger so continue I just I wouldn't
expound on that part
um well that was yeah that was pretty
much what I was going to say too like I
I just I agree with all of that that
um you know what we will see is a future
where Microsoft is not only looking at
Sony
as a competitor if they want to be but
the future of steam deck and the future
of 16 different handheld systems are
being released in the next two years
that aren't
um switch Yeah the switch Pro you know
has never come about so we can ignore
that Microsoft is looking at all these
different Avenues to create cash we know
for a fact Microsoft is working on a
puck the fire stick kind of situation I
run fire stick Cloud a ping of 18
milliseconds is completely doable in 99
of the games that I play and that's a
cloud side or that's a side load it's
not even like a optimized four I haven't
uh other than once got to play with
Samsung that's not the only deal as well
Microsoft has multiple other TV
companies that they're looking for LG is
one of them and and yeah TCL for sure
despite you don't like them
that's the walking thing but I was just
gonna say that I think Microsoft has
looked at the future and decided that
this very discreet way of everybody
doing things they changed years ago
everybody needs to remember micro
Microsoft and I'm sorry I can't remember
his name the head of Xbox
um
sorry the head of uh the head of
Microsoft
it took Phil over a week to come back
with the response of why should we keep
Xbox going and I can guarantee you 100
000 million percent that internally in
that discussion was all of this coming
about all of these changes and there's
no way they would have okayed the
Activision deal if they weren't looking
at something that is in response to that
so large I think people think
Activision's deal is Big I'm just gonna
personally say if you look at TVs pucks
all these other the Activision deal is
small and the reason why I say that is
because every single every single month
over 150 000 new Gamers enter every
single month into the ecosystem and then
the older people like ourselves myself I
think I'm the oldest here we still I
don't think so we stay
but we stick around
and we pay more and we also hold grudges
seventy dollar games what are you doing
yep and 40 games we also reward those I
just rewarded one where I'm like hey
forty dollar game yeah it's got some
issues it's a forty dollar game it's not
a sixty dollar game there's a game that
Microsoft's playing that's so far beyond
what Sony's thinking about and people
are con people are absolutely talking
about Call of Duty guys bigger than that
baby it's not the only thing coming from
Activision don't talk about it you know
what's going on sorry yeah and they're
big and when people start seeing some of
these things I think they'll be like oh
sh the what we know is awesome what we
can get in the future that excites
Gamers is what causes that pyramid of
growth where everybody at the base wants
because they're like What's the new
hotness and once they nail that
they're in position yeah look boss I'll
jump in and get my boss off um look all
fantastic points this has been the in my
opinion there's a part of me that was
like all right I am so sick to talk
about Call of Duty whatever but now
this is the funniest thing in game like
I am so intrigued by all of this now
like it is we have reached a whole new
level because like I said they opened
the curtain man they're like that's not
what you thought exactly you let us go
behind the curve publicly like this is
wild to me so look you know first they
go off I was Defensive on this
look he his job is to answer the
shareholders his job is to make sure
they're in the best position to protect
their interests and to me you damn right
he better do everything he can to stop
me and put anything on this deal because
it will do damage you know and look you
know the thing that's interested in me
is we got to talk about I always say you
got to follow the money sometimes right
look at the amount of Revenue that they
get from the Activision the Call of Duty
deal that is a huge Revenue pool that
they're looking out to shout out to
almost a z huge he added up he was like
um so anyway Activision Blizzard's
largest customer was their largest
largest customer in 2020 accounting for
17 of its sales or 1.3.7 Bill this is
what people are trying to protect here
right and we have to be very cognizant
of that so I'm with y'all overall that
at the end of the day I get it you're
going to corporations are going to
cooperate we get it you going to protect
your best interest you could try to do
everything you can to style me the only
reason why I gotta disagree it does come
off hypocritical is that the entire
basis of your business model was has
been exclusives and locking down content
to your platform right that's been kind
of your ml ammo and we've seen the
quotes we've had you know well hey if
you want to play that buy a PlayStation
yeah get it I was just gonna say that's
my biggest issues yeah caring like he
cares about the other right like just
come out there and say this is why we're
doing it this is our mindset like don't
sit here and be hypocritical to your
entire base on how you've been running
things the past 89 years because it
comes off as a title and it comes off as
as selfish because at the end of the day
the FTC and Regulators are not here to
just protect Sony's interests they're
here to protect Gamers does this is the
only one speaking up on that one yes
please they're the only one putting
their hands up you're ridiculous
well it just the more I think I listen
to us just discuss uh Jim Ryan and the
things that he's doing I'm wondering
just how much damage he's doing to the
Mind share of PlayStation which will
affect their ability to make deals down
the line they have they're better a huge
amount what what is right exactly well
they're bread and butter butter guy
covered brain
um has been you know getting those
exclusive deals and cutting those deals
left and right and the Damage that it
feels like his mouth and and his
policies are causing I think are gonna
do a number on their business model you
know two three years down the line how
many developers are going to want to
work with them Publishers are going to
work with them when they're so Keen to
limit who can have access to their
products right whereas Microsoft's like
yo yeah publish here cool no problem
we'll put you in other places and I
think that's the difference between Phil
Spencer who is often evangelized Phil
Dominus Maximus Aurelius uh
but when you when you look at the way
that Spencer is talking with Satya
Nadella Etc and and being willing to cut
the deals with people and be good to
people Publishers developers that's a
big Big Boon to bring talent in and
talent's gonna want to work with you
whereas if you're cutting people out and
you're talking down to them alienating
your fan base right a less enticing
business move two three years down the
line did that make sense
okay all right I'll expound at it like a
Red King I give it back to me is that it
the reason I I agree with you with the
damage there but the the interesting
thing to me goes is that he's willing it
shows me the seriousness of this deal
because if you're willing to damage the
public the public reputation on that
level you know what I mean and look bad
by doing this and any it's all because
to me it's like King said it's through
the lens of a businessman right right
this is a source that we could
potentially lose and past three years we
don't know necessarily what could happen
right right there's a little of
uncertainty there
oh God all right I think if I think if
anything this is their last shot chance
of doing it I want to give you guys a
homework assignment real quick because I
know King is going to go off yeah
this is short I want to give you guys
all the homework assignment
go and study what Sean Laden said when
he did his first Layton said when he did
his first interview about leaving Sony
he stated I was sustainable I wanted to
leave when PlayStation was at the top
and there is something inherently dire
about the person who has ushered in a
number of creative uh games to the
PlayStation stating that and I do not
think
that that was said in a gulf because
there were some a lot of rumors about
some heaviness going on behind the
scenes about who was going to be in
charge I just want to say go look at
that interview and see what's said and
what's not said and there's something
very forward-looking about what he said
in that interview where he was seeing
some things coming down the line no no
you're good it seems like we have Lord
uh Buck of Sony that's wild book
well let me Buck Up On You
now now dude the hat is so small
this hand is Big too though
yeah number one worry about number three
the point in time do we care about what
the hell they doing
when they start to dig in our backyard
I don't like what they're doing
and I'm gonna have to put a stop to this
you gonna have to put this down how do
you intend to do this sir I'm gonna
become a confidential Informer I don't
stop it I'm gonna snitch
you see
around here in these parts
you ain't gonna go do what you think
you're gonna do
you're gonna get that deal across the
table there now boy
I'm gonna tell you right now we got
enough bucks cause we number one and I
heard something ghost said
does it damage the reputation
they must bow down to us uh-huh if you
want to sell your game you want to sell
your game with a winner
attack
all the newsletters I didn't even
Galvanize the fan base by raising the
prices on stuff and I'm gonna tell you
it's not working so I got no other
recourse but to snitch
but I'm gonna tell you this we are
number one uh-huh and all developers
like winner now
it was inadequate
the deal that they slid across the table
uh-huh it slid me a couple of ones who
the heck you don't see any ones in here
I don't want that how would the deal
have been more adequate to you I'm
curious when we we give us Call of Duty
it started with us it ends with us it
finishes with us once you Buck up on me
they do not [ __ ] up thank you
PlayStation Studios Texas wow
Lord wow thank you thank you for your
experience we really appreciate you
listen to our Arlo podcast really do oh
yeah so now that's concluded
um yeah but look this is this is serious
King as well serious on so many levels
um I I am curious because uh HCG made a
good point I think this the scope of
this deal is much bigger as far as Call
of Duty the intentions of where it's
going to be and when this thing's gonna
go long term I do think though I will
say this it behooves them in my
Microsoft on some level two
Rectify it because the situation because
right now it's beef let's just call it
what it is like Jim Ryan's make these
comments publicly we know Phil Spencer
Microsoft they cannot be happy
internally right so the question now
becomes how they figure out because
here's the other thing that people are
realizing is that these two are still
working together and closely aligned
with Azure right and we have to be
cognizant that again
how does this affect things with the big
scope because to me as your Cloud all
that stuff is the big scope that's where
they intend to go and they intend to
have someone as a client so the question
is is it a leverage play are they trying
to push is it just to get more attention
on the deal yeah that's off it's
posturing it's just posturing there is
no beef there's posturing it's business
names no no I feel you and then and
they're gonna sit down one day over the
phone calls like you got me you got me
too yeah okay but at the end of the day
my man like that I'm gonna tell you this
we have but they're gonna do what they
again all's Fair Love and War and
business and this is business make no
mistake right it it plays out a personal
thing right in the public forum it's
business at the end of the day and it's
posturing and and like go said it is it
is Jim Ryan doing what he feels he needs
to do to put as much of a wrench into
this as possible and it's and it's it's
a back and forth between him and Phil
the fact that it got into the public
forum I don't think that Phil said
anything Phil to me again I don't know I
don't I don't know what the rules of
engagement are here what Phil said
didn't feel like something that that he
hasn't kind of said in a roundabout way
before uh you know when they asked about
Call of Duty before you know it was like
he he says we can't really talk about it
but at the same time it's like Call of
Duty is a big you can you can look look
at how big Call of Duty is and infer
what's going to happen with Call of Duty
um so that to me is posturing it's it's
trying to get it's trying to get maybe
more years out of the deal which I don't
think negotiation
um and it's just gonna Matt in the in
the in the the public forum what's going
to determine is okay who looks like the
loser who looks like the winner here who
looks like the victim and what can I get
out of looking like the victim right but
at the end of the day it's business I
don't think there's real beef they'll
figure it out we'll see oh I think it's
people but my question I mean my other
point though I do I do agree with you
though so off is that there's another
aspect I think besides the posturing
it's also buying time and I had this
discussion oh yeah with Maddie and the
reason why I think that he's ordered
something there is because I think
let's be honest in my opinion I'm just
looking for the outside in
the Bungie deal felt not that it wasn't
in place we know those these deals are
made long before right reactionary right
right but maybe the closing of the
bungee deal gets accelerated as a
reaction to once the Activision Blizzard
kid is announced and now we have Bungie
as they're going to be our Steward for
live service for 10 you know we got 10
games we're going to go in this
direction and to me like we have to be
this plant this is this is New Territory
for them you know they are the hashtag
just what the other they are the you
know third party third person cinematic
experience that's their bread and butter
historically this last generation they
ate off of third-party deals Call of
Duty was that security blanket that we
could have the marketing deal to the
common folk it looks like a PlayStation
exclusive you may get some maps some
skins go ahead I got anyone jumping I
think all you're seeing is the dance
between Jim Ryan and Phil Spencer
publicly speaking about deal for Phil
Spencer to get approved and for Jim Ryan
to get as much from the deal before the
negotiate businesses yes their
businesses negotiation soil Tactics get
yourself a position I I pretty much and
it's going to be interesting to see if I
want to see what or if Microsoft
responds to this particular thing or
just to settle behind the scenes that
that's pretty much so if you follow
history I did bring up Cold War because
a couple years ago that is what we were
talking about on a podcast is that that
is what I thought was going to happen
with these guys if you talk about Cold
War and how like Russia and America
handled the Cold War it was definitively
it was very on the on the front end it
was very antagonistic at times but on
the back end they had multiple treaties
they were both involved in yeah and this
is somewhat the same that you're seeing
with Sony and Microsoft where as you
were and all that stuff that's for
that's something that they're they're
they don't want to necessarily destroy
and at the same time I think it's cool
that Jim was like Hey you know I don't
like this I have no issue with him
saying that he's a business he needs to
get what he can but Gamers need to get
what they can and one of the problems
with Sony is extra cost for games extra
costs for systems lower bar of entry on
Microsoft's point but if you look at
Cold Wars 99 of the time cold Wars are
won by money and one thing that I just
don't even think people understand is
Microsoft's Financial footprint oh God
is incredible let me also State whenever
somebody say oh it's on PC not on
Console yeah on a Windows certificate
that somebody bought windows on which
happens to also be Microsoft so a lot of
people aren't really Gathering the idea
that Microsoft is so massive that a lot
of these things that we might think are
no way would they take a loss I I
absolutely disagree I disagree in all
ways I think Microsoft is looking at the
future where the numbers we see are
small in 10 years yeah I mean we've
talked about that Circle of gaming right
and how that yeah and we're all getting
into it every time you guys are talking
new people how many times have you guys
seen it where somebody says in your
podcast this is the first time I've
owned a console yeah it I we all hold on
to our book of Woe you know and we every
Grudge we write in with blood but the
new Gamers come in and that's one reason
why you guys mentioned when you guys
mentioned Final Fantasy yeah a lot of
people don't know the hotness the hot
hate that goes on with Final Fantasy VII
because of the Xbox removal like that
it's not there and they don't know that
some people are holding on to that so
some people come into this conversation
too and they might see this and go why
is everybody mad and they don't realize
that there is 10 20.
yeah it was raging on and now it's just
become a little bit more public yeah and
and I do consider Sony a little bit like
a Russian leader where they'll be like
of course
exactly what you say and then behind the
scenes they're like destroy them and I'm
not lying that's sort of the way it is
it's okay somebody's got to be Soviet
Russian somebody's got to be in the
United States if they're Soviet Russia
they're in trouble
just give me one second king is
Jim Ryan is sitting here saying this in
one interview and then he's going and
signing time exclusives later on that
day yes
I just wanted to say because ACG have
brought up a very good point that you
know you can get a subpar destiny
yeah and we can turn off the lights on
the azure
don't [ __ ] up
yeah be true that's true you send a poor
game over here that don't pass the smell
test yeah you won't have internet
tomorrow you might not have any Wi-Fi
hey Wi-Fi seven is not very good we
don't have Wi-Fi at all
how's your cloud gaming Sony how's that
working out for you you got games of
service
what if we turn that service off yeah
here's my question to you guys though we
got a wrap I feel like that is a lot of
money and I don't know if they would
sacrifice that business exactly for
something like this or like a a like a
console thing because I feel like
Phil Spencer's over in his little war
with this Activision thing and Microsoft
is backing it and then I feel like you
got your azra stuff and I feel like they
wouldn't let one stream cross into the
other stream if that makes sense like
yeah it's interesting they wouldn't
unless the deals continue to pop up like
this right that's what I'm saying is if
this continues Microsoft does have to
take a stand at some point
yeah let's get the likes of all football
Sunday appreciate y'all G this is on a
football Sunday yeah please keep this
out please get this out yeah it is let
me tell you something we have
unprecedented bars yes everything
listening
today
when you die on his side
[Laughter]
you know what it is King I talked to
Saul before the podcast and I'm like you
know what song I'm Gonna Leave You the
key out of the map
You Don't Have To Cross City do you have
to jump anything imma leave you the key
under the match
do you guys realize that the entire
worth of Sony is only 30 billion dollars
more yeah we can buy them all Activision
deal walk right inside and purchase
watch yourself
um welcome to the Sony Playstation Xbox
I always said it would be funny if they
come up on stage age one year and then
you see g-o-w you think it's Gears Award
it's God of War it's God of War and
suddenly it's like you got your dual
Sense on your Xbox you got your ex and
suddenly people are like what what
actually released a new thing I can see
Microsoft cut up there and be like look
like my dual sense over there I'm not
grabbing so think this is the Dual sense
look we know that we have you know we
have customers that plays over the place
that you like the Dual sets so well you
know we have people that like that that
like this controller I don't know can
you imagine Nintendo too they're just
like
what's happening
well I'm glad you mentioned the ACG
because that was before I forgot Da
Vinci was that it's so funny how we were
talking about all of this city it's a
Call of Duty and how it's vital there's
no other competitor and Nintendo over
here is sitting there switch companies
are so high all the time and they
released by the way Rabbids which is one
of my favorite got number two coming
people need to remember that Hardware is
six and a half years old when it comes
to its design yes and so I got I got the
game and I was thinking about Legends
Legend of Zelda yesterday and I was like
uh oh the new one won't be on a pro
switch it'll be on you know but that's
Nintendo
is anybody is anybody else exist outside
of our island or what yeah
it flies it is awesome because it's it's
awesome in a way and it flies right in
the face of all of this it's just like
yes it absolutely flies you know why
because they have they
aside from some back alley deals that
they did with like Toys R Us back in the
day where they got Genesis they have
actually done some really cool stuff
mixing in other companies things on
their platform and they've they've
cultivated fans that are unbelievable
they're a cult and I do say yes for sure
Nintendo fan and you're like dude you're
wearing a Mario hat like at dinner
we was we was watching the Ubisoft thing
in the um the the event for for rabbit
stuff came up and they were they were in
the chat saying this is this is acg's
favorite I thought people were trolling
me
favorite game on that system by a
thousand to one I would play only that
game I'd probably think the system was
worth it that's how good it is uh people
want me to review it
do it do it anyway
let's get the super chess back because I
I know ghost town is limited I I do want
to sneak so you I mean so do you want to
just go to the then we should just go to
the next stop because the only thing is
I'll get you first and you'll get get
your thoughts on uh Marvel and you be uh
we got Tony Bryant member for 26 months
glad to hear live got to be here live
also glad to see my fave people on one
place anytime ACG is here the energy is
amazing thank you sir
ACG might as well be a fifth Lord
I got a background for it
then we got face 23 beacan why twenty
dollars Super Chat thank you sir for
people who think this Activision
Blizzard deal is going to go through
without concessions that's not happening
yeah what yeah
we may never know about it
I don't necessarily disagree with
Facebook yeah long live black mamba two
dollars in King We Trust clearly
let's put the Crush in the chat for
acute perspective welcome to the Realms
I like that name
and we got the ever-born Saga five
dollar Super Chat it ain't Phil's job to
take care of Jimmy's kids hell dance
moves to pay his child support the book
of Acts
in a minute wow
then we got hargit to need 10 super chat
Jim Crying Ryan he sounds like a garbage
pail kid um says no game can match Call
of Duty that does sound like a garbage
truck yeah I'm sorry
meanwhile we have Fortnight League of
Legends pubg Crossfire Minecraft Roblox
Among Us and many others with higher
player counts than Cod yeah and let's be
the real things are cyclical at one
point Halo land you know what I'm saying
what like things can change man things
can change things can change for sure we
got God's hit man oh he's putting them
down for the
Lord's Day
ACG ACG go as Mac Man for Halloween
please
then we got Rel member for six months
two dollar Super Chat Destiny 2 don't
run 120 FPS on Playstation no feature
parody there's no parody there that's
not crazy
wow you don't be crazy if we did like
that week of the Halloween we did like a
costume Halloween podcast
all of us dressed as everybody else
except addict and I would switch and
people be like
so
you're dressing up in the background and
then all you've got to do is just have a
green screen in the back and we good
I'll be well booked then yeah
we got Carlos Alvarado two dollar Super
Chat as Gamers we need to demand better
from PlayStation
now we got Carlos Alvarado again two
dollars Super Chat PlayStation gets a
pass because they deliver games shaking
my head
that's not why they get a pass okay
we've got Spartan go 17 one pound 79
Pence Super Chat Jimbo leaking DMs like
a disgruntled ex
that's what it smelled like it smelled
like okay I'm gonna snitch
there we go Hardy today once again five
dollars for chat Jim Crying Ryan can't
continue to dominate without one
third-party game while Nintendo doesn't
have Cod and dominates both Xbox and
Playstation ironic
crazy Spartan go 17 once again one pound
and 79 pen Super Chat the Phil hovering
like pain above PlayStation HQ almighty
push
wow that's that's actually one of my
favorite villains in anime yes he is
oh then we have slim Ryan in the chat
it's him it's inadequate it's inadequate
we need Cod we deserve God for our loyal
payers
my issue with this statement wasn't him
defending his company his consumer base
my issue with him contradicting himself
on everything he's been doing and acting
like it's okay his job is to be a
hypocrite none of that stuff happened
we got chill Spencer aka the god of god
wow Executives
five dollar Super Chat stop snitching
stop bitching you better hope I don't
catch you backstage at The Game
Jesus
he's crazy he's ready he's ready to go
to jail
you don't want to see his
Phil sets him up to get people to turn
on gym yeah it does kind of feel like a
rope of dope
then we got hargit to need five dollars
of a chat just to point out Microsoft
said Nintendo not switch Nintendo will
be bringing a new console out and it
will likely have the ability to handle
Triple A games
yeah yeah it's not happening then we
imagine I'm sorry yeah go ahead I would
say imagine like you know Shilling for
the idea that Nintendo's gonna bring you
a technical Powerhouse yeah like what I
mean if the tickets
three to run on it but that was another
company
it goes to the start screen that's about
it yeah
they'll give you the most powerful
console they can give you while still
not taking an L on the on the console
that's oh for sure
exactly exactly
long live black mamba Super Chat Xbox
want to be like Disney plus Xbox will be
everywhere but the content in it will be
exclusive to the ecosystem you gotta
enter the Eco to get their games and
that is that's Game Pass
uh let me see Captain Logan five dollars
low gun stuff like that absolute five
dollar Super Chat we don't know how long
the original deal is but they get three
years past that of it coming to
Playstation at the same time yep feature
content parody that's what they said I
thought it was by game it wasn't by a
year though like the original dude was
like that he said three years beyond the
initial original contract and we don't
know what those contracts are yeah yeah
there's a there's been some inference
that it's 2024 where it ends but we'll
we'll see I hope so
then we got day one ten dollars a chat
Tim Ryan is a hypocrite and he knows
that yes he does he just doesn't want to
pay Microsoft every three years who
knows Cod might not be annually and like
I said it might not be annual anymore
and the deal will change love the show
and the guests are amazing that's all
amazing do you guys think that what do
you think the odds of them actually
making it by yearly
I mean like I said it's like it's a lot
of money to invest in a game that has a
lot of money they do but it is I don't
know it's kind of wasteful and you could
do I mean maybe they decide they want to
do different Cod products rather than
just an FPS you have war zone let at
least let every game that you drop have
a two-year lifespan where you release
DLC and Maps or whatever I don't know
and then absolutely be behind that in
every single way possible
I would buy those games probably yeah I
actually think one of the biggest issues
called has right now why it's like so up
and down is because like people keep
forgetting like the people who may who
are making Call of Duty now they started
two to three years ago like they were
starting on trans two or three years ago
like because they're having to get them
out so quickly yeah three Studios yeah
um
three calendars or three release years
if the latter Cod could be on
PlayStation PlayStation for all at least
six years more the thing is at this
point calendar and release yours is one
in the same because they they release
one every year right so I I don't know I
guess it feels like it could be a six or
seven year thing
um Raiden blade remember for one year
five pound Super Chat I'm just going to
point out uh this and point this out if
ABK loses this deal because of Sony ABK
will never work with them again
shareholders are looking forward to
looking forward to 70 billion yeah yeah
and that's I mean that's a big if like
that is that is a huge thing though too
like it didn't go through like the hard
feelings that would be I don't at that
point I would say this beef
I don't think Sony's trying to derail it
I think they're trying to use public
Outreach to have leverage when they go
for deals yeah it could be and we got I
hope y'all a little sausage voice I want
to keep up
[Music]
breath of the wild two will sell Bonkers
hey ACG he said what's up what's up
there's one before that is Raiden blade
five pound Super Chat I'm just oh no no
never mind never mind okay King
Christopher Hart to uh super chatted so
you might want to look at that we got
flame five dollars
howdy buckaroos I hope you all are
having a great weekend Xbox needs Cod
exclusive because Halo is an unmitigated
disaster I think that's a bit hyperbolic
but okay
needs a good shooter later flavor loves
getting that Halo there we got Lynch pin
with the 10 euros
happy Sunday to all the Lords and guests
just got my iron Lord title and Destiny
after skipping last season had to share
my joy with all of you cheers from
Germany hey I just want to point out to
you my my dude you went out you got that
iron Lord's tag and there's still people
I play with that don't happen
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do this
I wasn't even talking about you but
Kings wanted
say one more word snitch one more time a
car goes exclusive day one you gotta
talk like that why one more time in
those Azure servers stop working for you
audiobook you just did right there you
got the voices and everything yeah you
got the voice yeah
yeah shout out to Evermore because every
boy said the same thing in our private
chat say one more thing one more thing
one more thing
then we got to uh we have oh shut
everyone down
bones two dollar Super Chat this is why
I love Sunday's iron Lords don't miss
they appreciate you that's love lessons
God's hit bad two dollar Super Chat ACG
is Macho Man Randy Savage
one of my faves take it all right all
right Christopher Hart's next king
good reader the real news is how did
PlayStation 5 overtake switch is UK yeah
that is accurate in UK it over 2.11
months and he's caring he's literally
caring
yeah
let's just say it it's an inadequate
comments
I wasn't going to bring this up but
since you did yes
open the door you open the door open the
door I just love the fact how he likes
to bring up the numbers and stuff like
that I want to see you in a couple of
years
you know what's funny Christopher you
you you you you super chatted good you
chose to say some some inadequate
comment like that
Michael G5 Super Chat Xbox should
re-release all Call of Duty games just
to fulfill the contract and then release
a new Call of Duty eyes
Mark that comment
about remakes
oh no I've actually said that I wouldn't
be surprised if they started doing Black
Ops collections
and the fact that standard consoles
always pull more performance switch 2
will be more powerful than steam deck
and steam deck 2 will probably be out
that time yeah okay
Super Chat you're right SOB not a
disaster it's inadequate
go rice the bottle because stop being
messy well anyway okay all right that's
it because look real quick because I
gotta respect the ghost's time so I
gotta let him go first real quickly um I
know
hijacking I just want to get it no I
just go right here you saw four didn't
know if you got a chance to see it or
Marvel d23 didn't know if you get to see
it I've known you a big Marvel guy you
get into the pop culture for the ghost
so your thoughts on either or both well
I I actually watched the iron Lord
stream for Ubisoft and that was out of
pocket hilarious
um a lot of a lot of mobile stuff
happening on that one and I didn't care
a bit about it
I I'm interested in Assassin's Creed
Mirage mainly because it's a it sounds
like it's a more scaled back uh approach
we're driving all in on like yeah I
think that's gonna do well I agree
addict I mean they've got those games
are good but sometimes scope being so
big is actually a detriment to me I have
time man you know like I got only so
many games want to play
Odyssey was amazing though I had to give
them all to see I loved Origins and I
really liked Odyssey and you know some
people are origin some around you know
but they're both fantastic I like the
idea of scaling it back I'm curious to
see how they Steward the franchise
knowing that they've got uh 10 cent kind
of looming on the horizon you know like
what kind of UB sock are we gonna see
it's a good point good point uh Curious
on that one and then as far as uh
uh Marvel d23 that stuff I am really
interested in Amy hennig's games
t'challa's uh grandfather in the game I
think it was on iron Lords like years
ago that I was like you said that when
yeah I was like I want to see the
wakandans in a game regularly because
like the vibranium abilities just brings
so many possibilities for gameplay you
know and when you've got someone of Amy
hennig's caliber behind it that's really
really cool and it'll be curious to me
to see are they going to build this in a
as part of a greater universe is this
going to be its own contained thing
um I'm really interested in that I'm
just I don't know how we can not be
excited about that and then you know
like quietly like I'm excited for uh
frontiers of Pandora the avatar game
okay I I really wanted that game to come
out this year
um I was I was bummed when it didn't so
I'm hopeful that you know shows up well
but yeah those were the standouts for me
like I that that how can you not be
excited for Amy hennig's game and the
you know Captain America t'challa's
grandfather's in there I think it's the
chocolate is it t'chaga yeah
well to talk is his father oh okay okay
before I thought yeah I thought yes your
father but it's his grandfather so oh
yeah okay okay yeah yeah it is yeah
interesting time period too and I want I
want to know if they go there because
they talk about the Nazis situation is
going on at that time they could go some
places that would be interested that
could be interested yeah Marvel's got an
opportunity uh in the game Space with
that game to tell some good stories and
really I wonder Disney would like so his
grandfather's name is azzuri okay okay
cool cool no and then you know you have
to also wonder like is Marvel going to
go there in the film sense uh with X-Men
you know what I mean because it's time
to move forward right and so like where
are they gonna go as far as telling the
story of the X-Men I'm I that to me is
the most interesting possibility when it
comes to Marvel because with respect to
the Thunderbolts and some of the other
stuff that's coming out of Marvel phase
four has uh disappointed me
um which is a shame because like they've
made some high quality stuff I respect
it but it's not all been uh
yeah it's just not all been for me I
guess it's the right way to put it fair
enough fair enough you know I like it
has their own stuff midnight Sun's
looking good though and this year what a
weird who saw it coming out this year
when they died and I was like all right
gameplay
yeah and it's not February that's a
subtle jab at uh
that is ridiculous you're ridiculous
if you started noticing games more and
more because I it used to be games that
really released in December a lot but it
feels like the more time goes by the
more comfortable some of these
developers like December like after
Black Friday after Christmas well not
after Christmas will you guys get what
I'm saying like hey look at that point a
lot of the Christmas shopping's already
done so landscape has changed as far as
releasing I think because of digital I
mean it's so easy to get the game yeah
you know I mean it was yeah the Halo
infinite last year Calista protocol is
December this year Marvel midnight Suns
this year I mean you're you're right
addict like it's it's easier to get a
game out in December and it still sell
well then yeah shout out to the homie
que Asante the Annie Amy had a game was
co-written by Mark burn how do you
pronounce his name Bernard Bernardine so
he said he's sure they're gonna go there
that's a good point about that yeah
most likely they went there with the old
Captain America game
okay now I feel you close man look I
don't want to respect your time
obviously out but uh obviously if you
yeah if you do have to go I know you
know I'm saying brother I appreciate it
I know you weren't feeling 100 but it's
good to have you back nice to meet you
yeah y'all two need the link man shout
out to we did I already I already talked
to him mine nice nice yes Xbox expansion
pass I want to give you your flowers
brother you know one of my favorite
shows one-on-one interviews very
professionally done you've had the who's
who in the industry you're gonna say we
don't tell me you go back and forth for
the day of like yo how'd you get that
one no that was okay you're killing it
brother I'd love to see you shining and
telling people where the five people can
find you
I put his Twitter in the channel
what are your fans man I'm glad to see
you you're back on the platform so [ __ ]
telling people
yeah you guys can find me on Twitter at
insipid ghosts thank you addict for
putting it in the in the chat there of
course you can find the uh the Xbox
expansion pass all your podcast services
uh my my most recent episode before
tonight's drops uh was an interview with
Sheamus Blackman
and and they talk about they talk about
some deep stuff
um that Sheamus really hasn't talked
about in the public on here
fantastic interview goes fantastic
because again Sheamus I think he was
kind of surprised by by you know some of
the questioning and but in a good way
like he's like okay let's talk about it
and
um it was fantastic
oh I gotta miss it okay okay yeah I hope
more people were able to check it out
because Sheamus does he really opens up
you know what I'm saying like he really
shares a part of his life that I don't
think he planned to share and how it
impacted gaming and it can affect all of
our Lives which is really crazy yeah I'm
glad to think about so yeah if anybody
hasn't listened to that I would I would
ask and hope that you guys would check
it out because it was enjoyable
yeah cool brother again appreciate you
welcome back in the realm go support the
man no doubt enjoy your Sunday brother
feel better feel better take care thank
you thank you take care no doubt bro
ACG we gotta get to you now um not the
weekend you got anything because you had
as long as you want
um questions so did you get a chance you
be solved forward Marvel Disneyland d23
catch both of them one of them what are
your thoughts man both are we caught
talking about them together then yeah
um so both were utterly disappointing in
various ways but first of all
um whenever you tell me hey I'm adequate
a nice tight uh stream of our games and
one of the games is like I don't know 45
seconds to CGI and that was Disney
Disney's was really um they also didn't
show Spider-Man until the end in a 1.2
second little split uh it was it was
highly disappointing in almost always
because there was mobile there was a lot
of CGI there they didn't really push I
think what they could have pushed and
got some people really interested
because I I think they do and are
working on some interesting things Amy's
may be a little too soon to show who
does Amy is also cursed she's had
multiple massive games uh you know
canceled underneath her so I'm really
like rooting for this one because I do
follow her and I think that she's nice
to see I agree I agree yeah it would be
nice to see her actually ship again
that's pretty much what I mean yeah I
would be nice to see it end and I feel
the same way uh the Ubisoft create uh
what's her name um
jade Raymond I would like to see her see
some success like you just see these
people that are like almost there so
Disney's was an was ultimately
um pretty disappointing for me when it
comes to Ubisoft I'm gonna pimp one
thing I rarely do this let's go let's go
20 in 2020 August I talk about
Assassin's Creed Japan
go check that video because a lot of
people are like what
I did talk about a bunch of stuff that I
had heard and also just my hopes for
Japan I'm most excited about that
they did the perfect thing which is when
they announced it and they showed it it
immediately it wasn't Assassin's Creed
Samurai it was Assassin's Creed ninja
ninja and they have to because they
there are a lot of people even in my own
in my own video comments going why why
would I ever play that I'll just play
Ghost of sushima again I'm like sure
let's all just play the original Final
Fantasy let's just never again yeah like
that makes no sense so I'm really
rooting for that game to be good I
thought when I looked at ubisoft's stuff
there there was a couple issues the 10
cent deal which ghost talked about
there's some issues there that I
personally have but let me sort of
explain to you what I took from Mirage
not Mirage sorry the infinity yes so
Infinity has taken a long time to come
out we already know it's many years out
Infinity feels to me like Helix points
2.0 so Helix is already starting to show
and I like this I love playing Far Cry
and getting points to buy a suit in
Assassin's Creed yeah in fact I think
it's one of the best systems ever for
rewarding a gamer in your ecosystem I do
believe that Infinity is pretty much
simply
a new type of Hub yeah here's the
problem with the front end a lengthy
front end has never succeeded ever
because it takes too long to get into
your games they're gonna have to figure
out a way to where if you jump in and do
want to play Syndicate or do you want to
play Assassin's Creed which I'm assuming
and from what I'm reading through the
lines here you're going to be able to
play different characters in the Old
Worlds so we may see Jacob in Assassin's
Creed Odyssey that is my assumption that
we'll start to see that they've already
done the Skins so I would see them doing
that some of the stuff I looked at when
I did my walking walk for Valhalla
indicated that there was some meshing
going on where it was like how can we
replace characters there's some really
interesting GDC videos on that where
you're getting the idea of where
ubisoft's going so I was really excited
for that I also absolute damnation for
the mobile game and there's various
reasons why
first of all first game you can create
your own character it's on mobile yeah
it's in China it's on mobile their last
game that was based in China was a 2d
game and one of the worst games Ubisoft
now that was 2D so I'm not gonna hold
them against that but you just took some
features I've always wanted in an
Assassin's Creed game and I get that
there's mocap issues there definitely is
like my beard and mocap would drive the
world insane right you know they have to
have clean shape so I get that but I
wanted the ability to create my own
character and I hope Jade has that or
red whichever one is the Japanese one
um I what I saw there was them sort of
trying to say we get your we get what
your complaints are for long for for
length of time uh by the way that's not
the only Mirage is not the only small
one we know for a fact there's at least
one more other small one coming out
those ideas are awesome the idea of
going into a Ubisoft game like it or not
their attention to detail in Worlds is
probably the best and I truly mean that
I'm I do the walking the walks and I got
to tell you it takes almost a month to
do one game because they have so many
different things that they're working on
to make a world do what it does right so
I'm really excited to see that and um
once again
um I I was utterly disappointed though
it was trailer after trailer with just a
guy standing there and it was like it
was like Tron at the starting of Disney
when the guy's like are you excited I'm
like it's the trondis no I'm not excited
what what are you guys doing if you're
gonna do an event and I still firmly
believe something else was planned
because both of those events felt forced
they felt like they were trying to get
out of the way of the upcoming Sony
event and I'm definitely hearing that
there might be a reason why people do
not want to be anywhere near the Sony
event uh but I I was excited for what we
already knew there was no surprises that
those leaks had come out by the way
anybody out there if you signed an NDA
it also means you can't tweet about it
people broke NDA I'm sorry people were
breaking NDA left and right
for that it was loose
um and it felt a little bit like people
were lying they were like man you're not
gonna believe what you're gonna see in
the Ubisoft event and I was all
[Music]
what so overall I can't wait for those
games I like their stuff I want them to
pair some things down Mirage
looked a little old that's fine uh free
expansion for Ragnarok did you guys see
that and and Ragnarok you know hats off
to them those guys can't make a good Far
Cry DLC if they were if they had a
million years they're totally inept but
Assassin's Creed DLC is unbelievable
those guys take risks like most
companies hope to take risks roguelike
at Atlantis for Odyssey yeah that was
unbelief Jack the Ripper by the way one
of the best DLCs ever yeah
Syndicate so I'm I'm excited I don't
have the same hatred that a lot of
people you can smell the stink on them
you can smell their hate for Ubisoft
you'll see a review well it doesn't play
the way and you're like dude it's it's
their own thing I I get what you mean by
Collectibles I certainly do but I am
excited
for the idea of those games less so
Infinity I think Infinity is going to
turn out to be a front end that um and
they stated that it's not a game no
doubt you know they were very clear
attic you had these streams going
um Marvel and obviously you'll be so
forward thoughts on both I guess we'll
start with uh Marvel I
I guess the more direction we go towards
mobile the least I care I do think it
was a well-paced show just the content
didn't entice me at all
um I do feel like it was a good
astounding standing Foundation to doing
this in the future if once they actually
get the content they want to replace I
didn't care about uh I felt like it kind
of was like a little of um like a state
of play a little bit of that feeling I
actually watched that was like Microsoft
it's not hard do it exactly like that
exactly so true
um I'm also curious they showed
PlayStation stuff at the end of that and
uh it was in the little Montage thing
now obviously those games are exclusive
but I'm curious one of the you know
obviously we've seen Spider-Man on the
stage of Sony we've seen Wolverine on
the stage of Sony I'm curious if that
changes it now a little bit because
they're starting their own little
showcases because Mike Sony might make
the game but I don't know if they have
the right to say where they public or
what like where it actually shows up on
somebody owns Spider-Man's IPS the Lock
Stock and Barrel they they control both
of the car I was wrong I thought it was
impossible yeah except for the cartoons
and I was corrected so they own
everything Spider-Man they not
everything Spider-Man but game wise
they're they are able to absolutely
control that IP on YouTube okay what
about Wolverine
yeah so like part of me is like are they
gonna share that coverage with them like
you know maybe maybe have on you know uh
the next Marvel one where it teases a
trailer for Wolverine and tell you to to
tune in for some I don't know that's
that that's interesting
huh oh on Xbox only is awesome yeah so
that that's interesting now it comes to
the Ubisoft thing
um I actually did not like the Ubisoft
one at all like it it wasn't anything
against it I felt like it was it wasn't
really paced towards the way I like game
to game to game then you do the
interviews and stuff after it you you
know you you show the content what
people actually want and then after the
interview it's like look if you want
more of a breakdown and stuff we either
got YouTube videos or we're gonna do
interviews after the actual content's
been shown
um I do like the fact that I've always
felt like the people who came from the
original Assassin's Creed like me
I felt like we've always been left
behind because of the success of the
recent Assassin's Creeds but now it
feels like
they're everybody's getting something
yeah it feels like okay what we're gonna
do is they're gonna do like the Yakuza
Sega thing we're gonna have a mainstream
Assassin's Creed and we have another
team being working on the ones that
other people like the older fashion
Assassin's Creeds and I like that
because I feel like they're willing to
take the risk because they're amping up
Assassin's Creed development so I think
that's good
um it's like you'll be it's like uh ACG
I don't understand the hate towards UB
stuff like I understand that they have a
rinse and repeat content-wise but it
sells well so people like it so you
expect them to change up formulas on
stuff that actually does well now
obviously they I feel like they can do
stuff to make it more fresh but who am I
to tell a multi I don't know if they're
a billion or a million dollar company to
change up a formula that I like now I
played Far Cry six I loved it I thought
it was a great game obviously it was
more like it was more Far Cry 5 more Far
Cry 4 but I ain't enjoyed Far Cry 6.
I liked it man I liked it you know
Assassin's Creed I like the new
Assassin's Creeds but I I don't consider
them Assassin's Creeds if it's weird
it's like I feel like that's an original
ideal that they didn't want to risk
naming it something else so they named
it Assassin's Creed and it's worked out
well for them you know I didn't I kind
of dropped funhala uh I I was a real big
fan of Odyssey like I I have like five
or six days hell yeah baby it's I think
you'll be Sauced in a good place uh
Skull and Bones a lot of people are
looking down on that game don't sleep on
that game really you coming around
shout out to November 8th oh yeah
let me I don't think this game is going
to like revolutionize anything but I do
think it's going to find its own
audience if people are going to enjoy it
kind of like for honored I one thing you
could say about the crew yeah
Peru you can't make a crew here you go
one thing that you could say what you
want about Ubisoft when they commit to a
project they will commit to that project
you could buy any of their games and you
know even if that game
eight people playing that on Steam
they're gonna have new content for that
next holiday except for extraction
no extraction content during the Ubisoft
trailer
they should have just made that like a
little DLC thing for look at division
yeah what do you think what do you guys
think of division man that game is
getting low black screen that's all
black screen yeah I thought I thought it
was weird that division two was getting
stuff I I thought it was going to be all
Heartland that's it
I guess I guess maybe the division thing
like there's a lot of things I didn't
like about division two in I need to go
back and try it uh but maybe it's
because like I'm into so many games as a
service now that I can't open I can't
open that door to anything else and you
know someone said Mario plus rabbits I
think that looked that looked good I
wasn't the particular like I wasn't a
huge fan of the last one like I thought
it was good but it's just hang on I'm
canceling here that's fine that's fine
my email is
and it's just like but what I do like
about this is like they are putting more
coats on the gameplay you know the
Sparks I didn't realize what kind of
thing so you know you do might try to
reach out to a contact to try to get
that code I might review it I might
review it I don't know yet coming around
that's good no doubt solved man you'll
be so forged peoples see what's going on
and obviously Marvel d23 thoughts uh the
Marvel show I I kind of agree with this
everything was overall just
disappointing shout out to blessing like
that but he did a good job
um but yeah
commentator yes yeah yeah I thought they
did fine I saw some weird comments about
that but I thought it was I know yeah I
mean he's he's kind of funny and he got
a shot like that hey I mean it's
fantastic take exactly exactly so um
yeah for me coming out of the Disney
stuff though it really was just like the
Amy haddock thing that leaked beforehand
that's super interesting to me because
it's just like you know Carrick said
like she hasn't had it she hasn't had it
all a w in a long time you know her her
ragtag game got canceled and uh the
stall
so yeah this looks super interesting I
it it feels like an Amy game where it's
like okay let's take the the thing that
everybody sort of expects to come out
and put a Twist on it so to go back
World War II you know World War II era
black panther with with cap that sounds
great to me
um midnight Sons also looks very good I
I don't know that I'm sold on the card
stuff but you know for axis like what
can you say for Access that game's gonna
be great also solve if you get a chance
to check out uh Christopher odd he's the
one doing all of the that guy's got an
amazing deal dude and he's been doing
all the breakdowns very cool yeah
exactly killing it I don't know beyond
that like yeah it was it was a whole
bunch of mobile stuff that I I get it
like the money's there to make the make
the mobile stuff what was interesting to
me was the Gargoyles remastered like I
don't remember gargoyles being that
great of like I don't remember gargles
being in that Echelon with like Aladdin
it was kind of dope though it was I
don't remember it what was that sequel
no Violet Hearts too
hard exclusively to Netflix yeah yeah
yeah
and hearts was was very good
a lot of Game of the Year Awards for
about yes yes uh that world war one
story I think that was great
um yeah I mean that Ubisoft stuff yeah
that's very cool that they're still
doing that
um so yeah let's just jump to the um to
the Ubisoft just like ghosto I kind of
wanted to see what this Avatar they've
been working on get avatar game for a
long time yeah and you know you know it
again in a lot of ways it is sort of
like the Pocahontas story all over again
but I I remember going to see the first
avatar with King in new rock yeah yeah
3D
IMAX was there we got our tickets you
couldn't tell us nothing nothing Cameron
was it James Cameron yeah so uh I was
excited to see what that game is about
um so now jumping over to UB yeah you
know Assassin's Creed that's my baby I
don't know let me hear it no no I'm
gonna be listen to me they did the exact
thing they needed to do where ghosts of
tsushima was that it was more of the
Samurai thing
cookie cutter can I say why are we not
doing that we're not doing that so I'm
getting upset we're getting upset let me
bring the ghosts out here I finished
ghosts I enjoyed it but you know here we
go I've seen stuff in that game before
um I will say that was a good game I
don't even know what you talking about
yeah that's so disrespect I play so much
Assassin's Creed you have to understand
like I saw so much Assassin's Creed in
that game but it's fine my man is
Assassin Creed light that's what you're
trying to play now
what was disappointing to me about ghost
and what I think they did perfectly with
just a little significant they showed of
what red is going to be is the
differentiation between Samurai and
ninja because despite the stealth stuff
that they put in Ghost
the stealth stuff I played for a little
bit I was like
the AI isn't smart enough for the
stealth to really okay
so I was like I stuck to the sword
player the swordplay was fun the sword
players you was announcing yourself
outside yeah
let's go yeah I was about to smoke man I
was about to smoke I pulled up did the
little the little triple draw thing
killed three of them first and then just
exactly worked my way to worry about the
smoke if I can log into my place
so seeing what red could potentially be
and seeing what Mirage is and sort of
that return to to stealth and true
assassinations planning assassination
stuff like that so my thing is like if
they apply those things to red
see I to me that's like the 10-2
spiritual successor in an open world
right
it's true ninja like true ninja you
talking about the dudes that have not
done true stealth in a minute you're
talking about those yes
because this is the thing when you when
you show me you're going back to
something like Mirage I'm like okay you
understand that people want that style
of Assassin's Creed so to me
it's in their mind now right it's it's
part of sort of their design ethos it's
back to hey stealth matters right you
know we didn't see any Splinter Cell but
they Splinter Cell is supposedly being
remade whatever the case may be so to me
I see it as something like to me is
integral and the fact that they went
ninja ninja's about Stealth oh Freedom
oh for sure but adequately confirm the
developers these are the dudes that did
Odyssey correct oh yeah okay dudes
that's doing Baghdad which is I see I
see the open world I see the open world
because they said it's going to be a big
game right so I see the open world but I
do see them saying hey I mean there's no
re if you if you put a Ninja on the
cover and he just runs out there
I'm gonna be real with you I think this
is going to be an RPG like Odyssey
it for sure is what he's saying is that
because they announced ninjas it ha it
only makes sense
did it better I think they did it for
ninjas like
like kind of like like in certain uh
interpretations in like anime like they
they're gonna do more like Odyssey where
they have abilities and stuff that's
where I'm with like Shinobi and they'll
be able to do like ninjutsu's and stuff
like that as long as I can use the
shadows and stealth I don't care about
the power stuff that's cool okay it
doesn't need to be super grounded and I
can only stack if someone take half his
health that's what's about to happen
that's fine but but they always do that
you know you always have to level up and
they always they have issues with that
but to me I just got to get you for one
because you're so disrespectful to me
I finished this game and all honestly is
until they have a great I should say
their stories be good but until they
have that that dual combat that that
cinematic Flair right I want the
attention to detail to the time period
and what's going on then I will bend the
knee but we're not going to be
disrespectful but but you see you don't
play AC games
right so ACG said it their attention to
detail for historical I don't know right
that's right fantastic they're not going
to get that part wrong right I'm done
the only thing they could get wrong and
mess up is if they go in with cookie
cutter gameplay from previous games
right and don't make the game play
specific to what the skill set of a
ninja and to me this is their
opportunity to be like okay we this is
the thing right if you go in and make
this game and if it looks and feels and
plays like any other Assassin's Creed
game then you're saying you never looked
at ghost assistant Sushi and see what
they did wrong right so to me it has to
be that I don't see it being any other
thing if they do it's an L okay here's
how I think they're gonna do it I I
think that they're going to be having
games made like Mirage or isn't that
what it's called Mirage yeah Assassin's
Creed Mirage like those type of games
you're going to get another one after
Mirage that's going to be your your
classic 15 to 20 to 25 hours class uh
story mode where you do the Collectibles
and stuff and then you're out of there
you're at the back door like and then
they're gonna have the other people
making like the hardcore RPG stuff like
the Odysseys the origins now I don't
know what this hex stuff is that's weird
the hexes is some witch trial that's the
Witch and to me that's just interesting
because it's different than what we kind
of seen and we will see those more than
just those yeah because remember that's
how Primal was made Bible was made by
everybody getting together discussing
different ideas for Far Cry Primal one
out out so to me to me it's exciting
what they're trying to do with
Assassin's keys they they kind of
realize that they want to have the cake
and eat it too and go back to what
people are missing yeah and then try to
expand upon what they've been doing with
the RPGs because I I'm kind of like with
addict I Valhalla was so intimidating
and I know I don't get intimidated by
those games but I felt like it was so
much more downstairs than than Odyssey
and I played that a lot of Odyssey
um it just felt so much more
intimidating that was a question for you
yeah so let's make some guesses for
powers in in this because I think
breathing through the Reed while you're
swimming
did a very good job oh what other things
I think they're gonna have like a smoke
one where you vanish melting into the
Shadows yeah melding into the shout
grapple hook just like a Syndicate as
well your body can actually get into the
shadow on the floor and you because I
was just watching Super Ninjas uh the
other day and when the ninjas popped out
they popped out directly from the
Shadows yeah yeah exactly they need to
adjust that stealth thing right so you
feel like you're in style how many times
you guys played an Assassin's Creed game
where you're sort of standing there and
they can't see you because they can't
see you yeah they can in Ghost of
shashima to be honest but you just
standing there and they're like where
where is it you know
is great but it's a minimalist great
it's a totally different style of thing
and and I I agree with some I think that
we're gonna I love the idea of shuriken
smoke bombs
um remember their big thing by the way
ninjas actually weren't known to go like
Facebook
along with us you do some hit more flow
yeah
oh absolutely and that's what's exciting
for me about Mirage right we go we King
and I always talk about this going back
to that that Splinter Cell conviction
the original conviction where it was all
about social stealth and literally
dipping behind people
doing stuff like this in a in a
hallways
so to me all the things that they didn't
sort of do in ac1 yeah right yeah it
feels like to me because again they
started going in a different direction
with ac2 you still had your
assassinations but it was bigger they
got it right but there were certain
things that I loved about one in terms
of assassinations and the stealth feel
that they got rid of in two yeah so to
me go back to that glowing board
some really good social stealth in it
yeah and what I need is the what I loved
about one was the after the
assassination sometimes the blend in the
crowd you know what I'm saying remember
that the push balls
I I don't know how you guys did you guys
ever play the Assassin's Creed
multiplayer yeah
[Music]
because they're talking about initiating
multiplayer back into the Assassin's
Creed franchise I'm hoping that they do
something similar because like it was
like I remember back in the day like
you'll be hiding I'll be hiding here
what's funny is like me and my my dude
we we would okay dude if they see you
run to me run past me they ain't gonna
know I'm there you guys come out there
was a trick that they did in the
multiplayer too they would purposely
make some of the NPC's stutter step to
make you think it was a person in a
group you would have the eight you would
have you would have the like NPC walking
to be like
because it was third person I used to
like someone would see me I'll run
across run like like here's the wall
I'll be like right here he's coming this
way oh he's sitting there moment he
comes around I hit him right they were
gaming on them you knew if it was an
aggressive person you know you had to
play a different way what you do is
after you knock him out he's sitting
there for a couple seconds you run away
where you could still see him but he
can't see you because you're you're
paneling the camera around and then
he'll start running your direction he'll
come around the corner you get him again
get him again
that was the greatest I I understand
they they they they did it but I I to me
if they go back to some version of that
yeah that that's huge so in a nutshell
what I really cared about in the Ubisoft
show was the Assassin's Creed stuff and
it's exciting I thought Infinity was
going to be something else other than
just like this Hub but but but
um Carrick is right though they have the
best like the Ubisoft points thing like
if you play a lot of Ubisoft games you
get points for every game and it rewards
you and you could use those points
across all of their games right and just
get you know cool cosmetics and stuff
like that horse you're just like it's
cool man yeah exactly that's how you
reward Gamers yeah is by investing them
in your game instead of like here's some
coins I like the idea of like here's
some coins but they work in all the
games yeah all the games such a it's
such a cool knot anywhere else yeah
exactly
King cut that out yeah so and I got a
tease King a little bit I like teaching
a little bit so the the just just to say
that the only assassin they did not show
in any of those trailers was bum ass
alexios
I even show Connor they even show Connor
what's his name
no alexios though you best yourself for
that King your thoughts that Sandra is
the way you play that game oh my God
come on I got a controversial take
okay because everybody is so focused on
Oh Black Panther's grandfather Captain
America is like 200 years old right
right right you know so but um during
that period of time uh when Captain
America was uh fighting in in the War
World War II uh people forget who was
with him
you know you had the house
I had uh Nick Fury in the team but this
uh a little known character
and he uh has Adam atium in his in his
in his hands in his body
so can they uh up and Wolverine from um
Sony and get that game out with
Wolverine in the game playable with with
blood
um because I believe that this game is
going to be uh brutal uh because it's at
War times so it's not gonna be nice
um I think it's gonna have a mature
rating at some point probably
I don't think it's gonna be e for
everyone you know um because of the
subject matter and you know when you're
dealing with war you you know you try to
Shield the kids right so
I believe that and I'm going I'm gonna
go on record right now saying that
Wolverine is in the game oh wow okay I
will too I will I firmly believe that
he's a huge he's a huge component to
Captain America back then and when they
told his story they told how he fought
alongside the Howling Commandos and
Captain America and Bucky and all that
other stuff and if he wasn't on one side
of the war that uh Captain America
wouldn't have never got frozen in the
ice
um it's actually a what if book about it
um
cool
the
the Marvel Knights game
careful I love that I love the direction
that they're taking with the characters
you know with the they didn't tell you
why their suits are black and yellow all
right
um and they're going to explain because
they imbued with uh mystical properties
right so Captain America's shield is not
just uh uh animated and vibradium
combined uh Shield it's imbued with
Mystic Arts uh because they're going up
against you know demons and stuff like
that so you can't have the normal
you know to fight them uh the cards I I
don't know how it's gonna work and I'm
so curious about it because they they
tell you it's a card game and it's used
in this manner but I want to see it
right and I I don't want them to Peddle
me uh Dex you know I don't want that to
be the thing where they're peddling me
Dex oh buy this deck you know like v v
bucks and um NBA 2K you know um where
you can get cards ultimate teams crap I
don't want none of that stuff to
permeate this game I think this game can
stand on its own it's a it looks really
good uh okay another game that I took
from there was the kart racing game we
haven't had a good car for even game in
a minute and I saw it and I was like wow
I was looking at the world and you know
um I'm one of those weirdo dudes I I had
Diddy Kong Racing oh yeah Mario Karts uh
crash team racing all those and I I have
fun with it right so when I saw it I was
like oh that looks absolutely fun and I
can't wait to you know to get a chance
to try it so all in all I walked away
from their showcase it was a lot of
games that I didn't care for uh but
again if I can walk away from your
showcase and I can see two or three
things that I like for me then I think
you you did something good because you
have to show up in order to participate
right in order to get uh ranked right
okay so Ubisoft
start off with Wario rabbits and I told
you guys I don't love Wario rabbits yeah
I think
them using the Mario I mean the Nintendo
technology
and it seems like it's a first party
Nintendo game I know they send the guys
over there to work with them but again
at the same time the Polish on that game
felt like a Nintendo first party game
right and it came from Ubisoft and I see
the same level of Polish there and I
can't wait to get a chance to to play
that game the division let's go look
really good look really strong
um
what's the other game it it was another
game that I was looking at but to get to
the Assassin Creed stuff
I thought they hit it out the park wow I
thought they hit it out the park I think
I thought they went to everybody that
had a problem and addressed their issue
here's something for you yeah yeah so if
if you felt Odyssey was too big for you
is Mirage yeah you take it back you take
it back to when it was a simpler time
you punch somebody in the face into a
smoke bomb and you blend it in the crowd
and you walk with people you know um
take it back to where it was really
Assassins right you really did carried
out assassinations and it wasn't just
like random fight people in the street
um
and and I like that I I noticed too the
same time all that's going on if you
went to your Xbox or your PlayStation
Dash I don't know oh yeah it looks
beautiful 15th anniversary stuff right
was uniform I saw 10 cents money being
put to work
right off the brick right
um
so you had the the mobile stuff
I'm not opposed to it okay just because
I don't understand it and it's not for
me money maker doesn't make me opposed
to a New Direction and how to play
something right so it may not be
marketed to me and it may be marketed to
somebody else and the dance uh Universe
game of dance versus game
um that's marketed to somebody else but
somebody shared that game on now when
you got to the ninjas
I always told people go to sashimo
was
Odyssey light oh yeah
uh for dummies games
and I did and I didn't uh right so like
I can't do that you know because I can't
get inside my console yes
we blame the social security for you
yeah I gotta I gotta blame them when I
call them they say call back tomorrow
because you tried too many times today
um I got a problem with them I don't
want to change my name I want my two
games that I I should have never gave me
my money
um
that
that that those games
that Ninja
it could rival ghost he saw a cinema no
no no no no no no and the reason why I
say this right
the reason why I say this I mean Sony
has this the the the third person story
driven thing down pack
and we got it in in Japan we go to Japan
and dudes went Buck bananas right it's
the same thing with the Last of Us same
thing with this same thing with that but
they did it in a Ubisoft style but they
did it light okay right it wasn't too
heavy wasn't too heavy-handed it didn't
give you so many things on the map that
made you feel overwhelmed so a lot of
people was able to get in play what they
wanted to do get their objectives go to
a nice story and have a good time
ninja joint on Ubisoft they might do it
really right and historically when I
played Origins and this is the reason
why I'm absolutely completely hopeful I
have walked away from Assassin's Creed
before Origins if he's with Microsoft
and he was sliding down the pyramid yeah
and it was the 4K joint and I was like
oh my God just shimmering off the
pyramid in the Sand Dude even the people
build things in that when it's it's nuts
you saw the museum thing
you really respect King have you gone
back since the the 60fps yes
Goosebumps
um
I have faith in it
that it's going to be that ninja game
that we want that we ask for so what I
saw them do
was they took all aips
and they said okay how can we address
this
uh you know Rainbow Six Siege mobile put
that out mobile was for everything so
everything across the board had a mobile
game all right we we knocked that out
the park now we're going to address our
Flagship now
that's skull and bones
I didn't know I needed it until I saw an
attic have come around in this okay
until I saw it
water physics absolutely incredible
the fact that you can dress your ship up
to to be a juggernaut or or to be a
little uh a smaller ship to get around
maneuverability
it was so much that was going into it so
many layers that I saw into the game I
said this is not an afterthought this is
something that they're actually uh going
after this this is something and they
believe in it so strongly November 8th
they're going up against somebody's head
yeah
um and I felt that was fantastic
because you believe in your product and
I told you guys before anytime you
believe in your product you don't move
your date you believe in your product
you stick on your date and you make that
other dude move
and
Ragnarok is coming out this year oh oh
it's DLC it's DLC
DLC for my house here we go so so I mean
King King come on just bend the knee now
do you think in your personal opinion
you think uh God of War Ragnarok getting
delayed till next year
no okay you said his personal opinion
you the dude hiding from the cops
and you don't know if they're gonna
fight they got to get me
going down I'm not gonna walk you the
person saying you ain't got me you know
what I'm not gonna walk out and say you
got me not you don't got me until I'm
God
I know the chat be loving you chat put a
one if you think King been in the need
this November or put a two if you don't
think I'll detrimental will this be for
you um
I don't even want to turn it into this
but I'm telling you until I'm in the bag
I'm not okay I'm a rabbit you got that
rabbit around his head and you put him
inside that bag and tie the knot at the
top
so when when that day happens just give
up no I won't because I've seen other
days other games have pre-orders I see
people put their money down and they say
well you know know what I know you put
your money down for November but I see
you in January and we're gonna give you
so King thinks Ragnarok is going to be
delayed yes yes he thinks that yeah I
mean so I don't think so but I wouldn't
I mean so what happened big surprise
what happens when it goes gold right is
that the day that you've been the knee
when it comes out no he's gonna when it
comes out
yeah
we've taken one and acting like that's
the same time
he wants me to hop in a pot and get
cooked
I mean
I'm trying to wait though
if I if I'm gonna get the gold medal why
can't I have it now
see the rest of us here are old enough
to know
it ain't over to the fat lady saying
yeah the only people that say that
people that know the fat lady's gonna
sing yeah but I'm gonna tell you this if
it goes my way brother if it goes your
way
every Sunday he's sick I thought Ubisoft
show I gave um
d d23 uh you know I gave this show
a seven okay
and I give the Ubisoft show an eight
because when I went back to watching I
had initially gave it a seven when I
went back to watch it
I said well you know they have way more
stuff there for me that I that I really
was joking around with and playing with
I never brought Valhalla because I
believe in Phil Dominus Maximus are
really expensive I don't trust him the
moment I put my money down to buy that
game it's gonna be in Game Pass I'm
gonna be sick to my stomach so I'll wait
for it to get the game pass in our Biola
DLC I will do that
I don't trust them
so I don't know about you guys yeah oh
I'm sorry no go ahead no I'm just gonna
say I feel at the starting of ubisoft's
event if they had just went and showed
the Splinter Cell glasses yeah and been
like
of 100 it's time for that yeah Beyond
Good and Evil 2 is for sure being made
and you had spoken up that when Ubisoft
does believe in something they will
continue like and admittedly I joke with
you guys and I've talked attic a little
bit about Skull and Bones you know
whatever but when when when they do
believe in something you're absolutely
right like they they definitely I mean
they definitely support stuff yeah like
it's it's hard to really take it away
from them I will also point out the God
of War producer is not um active on
Twitter and it's something that uh Carey
or Cory balrog had pointed out just
don't expect as much stuff from him as
you do from me
um so I I don't know if that's your
belief or delay did was there something
you would stop
oh sorry so that was the stupid guy he
just believed yeah what it is what what
it is is this
we have not seen gameplay for the game
right we saw some little Snippets here
we haven't have a presentation oh no
this is our joint and it's getting ready
to come out so either one that arrogance
is taking you so far for granted or it's
exactly what I said it is in this
complete DLC right so they don't want to
show it to you right now because they
don't want to hurt sales or their
arrogance is so high that their sales is
going to be so crazy
I can see that thought process right for
sure so so now
in January or February they're still in
their uh business fiscal period right
they don't miss
so everybody is all caught up in the
business uh in the holiday season oh
they got your king they got to make the
holiday season if they don't make the no
a game of that magnitude doesn't have to
hit Black Friday it doesn't have to hit
Christmas it doesn't have to because
those people that do have a PlayStation
that are in the market for that game
they're going to buy it whenever that
game drops and Sony knows this so if it
does need a little bit of polishing or
if it doesn't align with certain things
and strategically they have to put it
for this or for that that's the only
thing but I don't see it hmm
that's why I said something's fishy in
Denmark
fair enough look I'll jump in if
everybody got any balls off about to be
should be quick
um look for me so I'm just gonna be
extremely selfish there's only two
things I really cared about on both
sides I do not really care about I mean
I should say that I mean yeah man for
the um Ubisoft yes you know I know so I
feel strongly about sass Creed and
that's his heart that's his baby I've
cooled off for the Assassin's Creed so
for me this actually was for me to show
me that they're going with this approach
to kind of cater to guys like me that
like the original like I'm actually
curious about the one in Baghdad because
that seems to have some of the
sensibilities that I like I liked when
it was like old Jerusalem and just
sneaking around and I like that stuff so
that for me you know resonated you know
the newer stuff they're great games I
just don't feel big or Assassins Creed
okay like to what the letter of the law
I grew up with the series with so cool
to see they do that of course when I see
Nicole red I'm like it's about damn time
you know what I'm saying like this was
your or get out of jail free card like
acg's like when the business is going
down the fiscals are going this is what
you got to do it's the same thing if
Forza ever gets to the situation where
yo the numbers is looking alone let's do
that Tokyo race drift you know that's it
absolutely you know what I'm saying like
so I get it you you pull it out the
stops it's about time yes off I will
give you the ninja aspect excise me
because yes go to stream is a story of a
samurai right who's betraying his code
to do something else and it's an
internal struggle so for those who are
ninja fans shout out to the cops and
ninja fans too but you know though like
for those who are true pure ninja fans
it's not embracing the entire ninja it's
giving you this choice to remain
honorable or whatever I get that I'll
I'll give you that still not gonna let
you disrespect the story I'm still not
with this the world the culture the
duels everything about that game
15 minutes into that game that's like 30
30 minutes into that game I knew who the
real villain was
and that to me was like oh it's they're
not breaking the mold all right I'm not
saying they did nothing
completely different but all right all
I'm saying is with it well where you get
to that point it's an emotionality to it
and there were some points in that game
where I was like yo the game really
showed hard I didn't expect that from
the game so that's it but of course I'm
biased yes I know so at the end of the
day
yes it is what it is so the thing is
with this though will they do true ninja
and it seems they are like I think
everything I need I need my smoke bars I
need my shirts can I get some countries
well that's the thing and that was my
beat for that game was like I was
excited for the ninja aspect of ghost
right and when I got in there like the
first I would say four hours of that
game I played I tried to do the stealth
I'm hardcore stealth and again the AI
wasn't smart enough for for the stealth
to feel rewarding but what was rewarding
was going in there and announcing myself
murdering everybody I will say that the
stealth in its defense you have to
unlock all these different things before
you can truly play the stealth way but I
agree the samurai way is the accessible
way and that's the thing I did all of
that and and that's when I was like I
was I'm op now I'm super op yeah and
it's not even fun to kill them and she's
doing is the slice the one right through
two three you're doing your timings and
all that I got you let me ask you this
what happens if they give you your your
Japan thing but they go like the Odyssey
way where you can't just seek up all
people to assassinate them words it's
more about Bill like I'll play it I like
in a world with all these abilities and
stuff because I I feel like that's the
direction they're gonna go because at
that point is ninja guy yeah it's ninja
guided yeah and if they do that I'm not
I mean I'll play it all right but I'm
just not gonna be I'm not gonna put it
back I feel like if it was going to be
that way they would have worded in a way
that makes it more on the words with
like Mirage like it's you know one of
those type of titles but they
specifically said RPG and the people
that made right Assassin's Creed Odyssey
are making it so it makes me kind of
feel like I don't think that's what I'm
saying though what I'm saying
all those things that we expect out of
the Stealth gameplay and Mirage apply it
to the open world with a ninja and I'm
fine with it as long as the stealth
feels rewarding and real and it's
stealthy because again if you make a
ninja game and it's not RPG or not if
it's not stealth oriented you're making
ninja guided right you're doing
something that's going to be more like
Ninja Gaiden I I don't I think there'll
be stealth mechanics in the game but I
don't think it's going I think this
game's gonna be centered around RPG and
they'll have stealth mechanics in it I
don't think it's one thing to remember
too is that Valhalla I mean I didn't
love it I liked it more when I've
returned to it but Valhalla made a
billion dollars yeah
um Valhalla the ninja one is going to be
Valhalla it will be it doesn't mean
I was able to kill I don't know if you
guys if we played differently but I even
in my walking the walk I killed like 77
people without him seeing me oh no but
but it's not but yeah you could do it
for sure you can do it and it's still
there the thing is it's not rewarding in
the way a Splinter Cell game is right
it's it's totally different right well
yeah because you're a viking right
because I mean the idea of stealth to a
viking is put it it really is but but
the thing the thing about it is is like
to me even if it's an RPG if you're gold
ninja the Stealth gameplay has to be
Paramount the game has to be built
around it but what Paramount mean to you
I need to ask him this because I'm
trying to figure what do you mean by do
you mean so remember you have to build
the powers and that's one of the biggest
problems we have and it happened it goes
to sushima where you're like I am an
amazing Warrior who has to learn how to
walk and you're like how did he lose all
of his powers it happens to all games
right yes yeah what do you when you mean
Paramount what do you so take valhalla's
and there's a village and you're now in
the the the ninja one what is exactly do
you want to see the engagement be
differently than valhalla's stealth
which wasn't great because you are what
are you are you hoping for like it is it
is a it is AI that it's that's aware of
of of of sneakiness right that is
looking up onto rooftops uh making sure
like when they hear something
investigating all their own accord not
you you know throwing something and
trying to distract them oh God it is it
is AI that is that is focused on trying
to capture someone that is trying to be
sneaky right and and you want to be less
powerful because you are a ninja
yeah that's what happened
I hope that you guys are right because I
think that would be the better game but
I think it would be I think it they
would have marketed it without the RPM
that's a lot of AI
[Applause]
jumping on top of a roof
once they brought in and the first thing
they said is this is an RPG like that's
the first thing out of their mouth
they're like to me this is going to be
around like the world of a ninja like
and it's not it's going to be more
fantasy that like Odyssey was where you
have abilities you can upgrade them I
don't I think they'll have stealth like
you can kill like the no-name people as
far as like captains generals like
people with a vast of amounts of Health
like I don't think you're just gonna be
able to assassinate them like and I I
don't want to go back I should point
something out though you can adjust that
now in Valhalla and I think one of the
things that people are not remembering
is that Ubisoft does have a tendency to
try stuff in a prior game including
options and then build them directly day
one into the next game so if if SOB
wants to play a ninja I am personally
assuming that he will like steal Rising
just did where they took a somewhat Dark
Souls game and allowed you to adjust
massive parameters I would assume that
if he wants to play that way there will
be a button which does exist in other
games that you can assassinate anybody
can considering
considering this is you know the one
everyone wants there might they might be
serious when they say there's a stealth
pad like you can literally go stealth
personally me I feel like the fact that
the Odyssey team's working on this and
the fact that they promoted it out the
bat that it's an RPG I feel like the
game is going to be built around an RPG
and there'll be some stuff but if you
have options addict who cares right
it's day one to just go in and click and
say I want this to be super hard because
I hope they do that way 100 I play it
that way if they don't they are losing
out big time if they don't they are
making a massive mistake if they don't
have the option in there to say yeah I
want this to be cranky hard to where
you're like
about the RPG stuff that now that you
know that that addict mentions it is the
fact that uh Ninja
's can literally be see anything
if you don't if you don't give me the
option of just being a pure ghost and
not being seen that isn't ninja either
so it's like but again that you don't
have much of a game there I guess if
it's not if it isn't like a Splinter
Cell game right so I I don't know man
the RPG stuff does kind of put them in
certain Corners that historically
doesn't play well with with Stealth
gameplay pure Stealth gameplay
was working there he'd be going like I
want to do this and it's hard to do that
yeah let me ask it's going to be
interesting let me ask you a question I
see G like I don't know do you think
maybe because they're making the mirages
they're trying to separate the two more
personally that's what I originally
that's what I said yes that's they're
trying to like look if you want the
stealth stuff go with those because Subs
right you can still do this you can
still take Valhalla especially if you
level up in Valhalla there's a lot of
stuff you can do I think he's right that
they looked and go and went okay we are
missing out how can we marry this stuff
admittedly if they had reversed valhall
and done it first and then done Odyssey
I think this discussion may not be
occurring Valhalla had a a dissonance
that was instantly noticeable even
though I liked a lot of the story and I
love canoe by the way the voice actor
for my mail elvor I love or avor
um but they had a dissonance that was
instant which is Viking stealth yeah I'm
sorry yeah
it's going on exactly it was Odyssey
where it was less about Stealth and
about you know the the warrior of the
time and stuff and it was such they did
a better job in that game Valhalla have
a lot of issues so I think the
discussion would be different but um
yeah they're separating them I think
they've made that pretty clear that
Mirage is its thing old style I'm okay
with that because I don't think they
won't have a ton of options I mean
Ubisoft look at ubisoft's options Pages
guys it's nuts it's like three pages of
options and I would love for them to say
you can instantly assassinate but you
got one shot and also solve I mean
because this is what I studied in
history is uh Samurai versus Ninja even
though ninjas aren't anywhere near what
we've blown them up yeah
um but the idea of the straight sword
versus the curved sword the counter
attacks that were definitively used uh
by ninjas versus Samurai would be very
cool to see a countering system built in
where it wasn't hit why I'm not dissing
on Assassin's Creed read but it is hit
white a win yes yeah even when it's they
say it's not so the idea of let's say a
countering system and what we saw in
goshima with the different stances
and that's what actually happens is
instead you're a ninja you go train you
get a new stance and now it's all
counters so now you're you're you have
to be good right yeah it's not soaking
up damage that's dumb Valhalla can do it
because they're Vikings but a ninja I
love that idea I mean it should be like
Spies versus mercs whether where the
spies are weak exactly yeah exactly they
should feel underpower it's you going in
infiltrating against these Unstoppable
odds like it's what gives you the that
Joy right when you do that and you play
it that way that's what gives you the
joys coming through the other end and
not dying you know what they might do
they might build like the original Thief
like I might be thinking because of how
they did Odyssey but they might build
the game around being stealth like you
have those options to sneak around like
the thing that King said where you can
go in the Shadows literally like they
might give you that option to stick
around maybe you know they're going to
highly push you to be more stealth than
just going in their guns blazing yeah
sorry no go don't go completely I think
you yourself as shown that know how how
no matter how powerful you are
how high you grow as a character in the
world there's always one dude that's red
yeah yeah right and I think that like
you said and I'm I'm tending to agree
with addict right it's going to be an
RPG you're going to learn these moves
and your stuff as you go along
or whatever but I also agree with
Carrick
that they have these sliders
and I like you when you agree with me no
but see if y'all all have valid points
right you all play the games completely
different and Ubisoft exactly and
Ubisoft knows that that's what I'm
saying yeah so I just feel that it's
going to be a blend of everything but I
think it's going and this show has shown
me that they will cater to all
if they give solve his uh like I would
like to play like Saul but if they give
everyone the option to play the game how
they want I think that's the correct way
I don't do like soft yeah like I I will
like you see when it comes to Splinter
Cell I'll play a couple of different
ways I play full ghost and then I play
American murdering right yeah you gotta
switch it up man yeah play at the
reverse the way the game wants that's
the first thing I do if the game's like
do stealth I'm like nope I'm gonna go
out there and see if I can murder
everyone yeah and yeah yeah I play that
like I play everything I I attempt to
stealth but the more I get caught
everybody
and yeah and the camera in the tents
doesn't help if you get it just by the
tent oh the test is rough I'll give you
that yeah
this land is good I know did you see it
I'll give you that well thank you
you know what game doesn't let you if
you fail you're done is hit man hit me
he is the worst when it comes to a gun
fights but they pretend like he's not
you know Sylvester Stallone is really
like when outside of The Expendables
pool filming where he's just like oh
everything hurts that's the way Hitman
is yeah I just all said is um with this
joint the only thing that gives me hope
with it is the fact that they actually
said Shinobi simulator so that's true
before that that they are trying to
embrace it you know what I'm saying and
FYI you know that Shinobi means magic
though yeah yes okay we know exactly
which I'm fine with of course of course
if you have the mystical nature of it
great if you have an animal yeah if you
have some spiritual to justify to go
against the odd thing no Shadow Dancer
yeah that was fire that was fine but
yeah they've got a lot they've got a lot
to live up the ghosts beat them into
space I don't care what anybody say yeah
they did um and at the end of the day
they're still the thing that ghost did
it no one is giving enough credit is
essence of the duel the essence of the
one-on-one matchup where it when if you
are discovered right and you are not
like they had a boss level presentation
that look that hell would cling there's
nothing I've seen from Assassin's Creed
anything remotely to that that's the
essence of it the windy backdrop the
cherry blossoms the bro that's Japan to
me so they gotta I'm confident in the
culture I'm confident in their world
building and I'm confident that as far
as like they're they're AI as far as
like moving around stuff I give them
that but I I need them to execute that
perfect match because that's why ghost's
ghost is beloved and the thing is if
they do that great you know what I'm
saying I mean I'm just happy they doing
it that's the main thing
you know what things what's a little
disappointing it they didn't touch on it
which means I don't think they've really
done anything in that regard as a the
engine like I'd like to see a new engine
I really would like to see a new engine
yeah yeah it's just it's too ingrained
like it's I'm doing an interview with
them in a couple weeks on their engine
from because they'll walk in the walking
um they've made huge strides but I agree
a lot of these companies are reusing the
engine and calling it a new name right
is it are they using Snowdrop or Anvil
what are they doing it's an bill it's
Anvil 2.0 by the way that's why we're
bringing it up and uh and by the way the
things that they're doing with Anvil 2.0
are ridiculous okay like some of the
stuff I saw for was mind-blowing in how
they tested it like they would go home
at night push a button and they would
teleport the character 15 feet randomly
everywhere in the world the next day
they would come in and they would have a
readout to say what was loading slow and
what wasn't like they have all these
really cool ideas and then somebody
would go and raise up a ladder a little
bit too far and break the level and
those are the kind of things that I want
to see fixed is like the Jank because I
liked Valhalla at times but man bro
you'd see like animations you know going
off where there was no character in the
screen and you're like that was it was
rough it was a almost too big for them
to to properly QA yeah and that's what
I'll say is for the other show
um again selfishly all I cared about was
a bit nice
midnight Sons man I Am Lord turn based
that's my favorite genre um oh you know
yeah for axis full RPG full yeah like to
me Jake Solomon and faraxis are the
goats green now when it comes to their
space there's no one that does it better
salute to the OG that made Phoenix point
my man forget his name right now oh
forget his name and I like that and I
love that game don't get me wrong and
he's Yoji from back in the day with XCOM
Discoverer UFO he's that guy but Jake
and Nancy shout out to Mark NADA um
addict who we had on who who did um who
worked on XCOM 2 because we feel XCOM 2
is one of the goals as far as Turtle
base and he did Chimera Squad and we had
him on IOP but it looks like to me for
axis finally got the big Market bag to
be trusted with the Marvel IP right so
I'm curious to see yes there's going to
be questions because cards is kind of
new but then again I'm a demial fan and
if they do it right right you know and
you got it could potentially work now
with King hopefully you know
modification I think I would hope not
that that scares me yeah I I would hope
I know but this you may get a valid
concern right they got a whole season
pass yeah they did Bonkers with that you
know what I like here I like that they
picking more of the grounded street
level MCU guys like you know right blade
we get for that I think okay Marvel
Knights are aren't that right aren't a
couple of those people that they have
there right it's definitely not Captain
America
um
I think they had to pick what was
available Maybe
and and they went through the list of
some of the dudes that was there and
then you know they added some other
people that was there uh but I think
they they had to go with what was
available and I like the usage yes of
what's available like the Scarlet Witch
yes um which she's not in in the Marvel
nights uh but you know and Captain I
really gotta say Captain America he
threw me when I saw I was like
you know it's that stuff but sorry no no
I just think that it they're the best in
the turn-based space and I'm dying to
see them with Resources with a bag and
they remember I thought man I thought
Jake and The A Team of araxis was
working on XCOM 3. but it come to find
out this is where they at and Nikon
three still in development somewhere so
I'm curious to see where that's gonna go
so I'm excited man and then shout out to
Amy I gotta give her you know to see her
I'm pulling for like ACG said we need to
win basketball hard yeah I love her
since bro
I mean Legacy again I'm talking about
original blood
I mean they didn't announce those on
their embracer let them announce it oh
that's the big thing I covered it in my
news video embracer did not say we have
these IPS they let those companies State
we have to be from Deus Ex there is a
Reason by the way for sure that is now
one thing Lars has been open about is
his version of AAA as in everybody
else's yeah I mean he's a little bit of
a money pincher but I think Legacy of
Kane Thief maybe Deus Ex I do see those
being almost instantly working yeah yeah
for sure I mean it's I got a little I'm
a little nervous because of how Saints
Row turned out but wow a little nervous
yeah you should have like sphincter
Titan
well yeah that's pretty much what I got
again I love world now where today's
gaming tomorrow's game yeah yeah and
patches and fixes happen because
absolutely true I go back to games and
that's Ubisoft stuff sea of Thieves yeah
yeah Ubisoft handles that stuff so well
when it comes to Ubisoft stuff like uh
you know Siege uh for Honor those games
yeah are not the same yeah we gotta
watch with the 10 cent bag go we just
gotta watch yeah yeah but I saw what
they did with the tension back they
changed the logos but look I said I'm
curious it's a great concept you know
black panther cap looks like some type
of uh dominate I still think Wolverine
for sure I believe so great and then
obviously some type of soldier of the
time period so it's a four character
Focus pulling for Amy do her thing
sounds great but yeah that's pretty much
what I got on it I'm gonna give you some
chance move on so yeah hold on a second
so we got done a taco member for one
year ten dollars to the chat Captain
America and Black Panther game look cool
until I remembered it was an Amy Amy Amy
henna game and after hearing her
interview she confirmed the gameplay
will be mediocre like her previous game
oh boy don't do that
I mean
Uncharted shooting has never been great
right a charger shooting has never been
amazing right
um you know I think they understand that
they they the hand-to-hand combat in
this game has to be you know on point
you know so I to me I when I think about
Amy I think about the writing I think
about the story I think about the the
subject matter that they're gonna tackle
that's what I think about everything
else it'll be fine like she didn't have
anything to do with the gameplay per se
I would say when it comes to Amy Hennig
in terms of like in
let's see what she produces before we
start assuming what she's going to
produce yeah
we got Donna Taco again chat what no one
is talking about is how Valiant Heroes 2
valiant heart is only on Netflix I've
been waiting for a sequel for so long
and this is how I get it also Mario plus
Rabbids 2 is top five game of the year
for sure yeah I'm gonna tell you what I
tell everybody man like I tell you if
you want to play final Fest you probably
got a Netflix subscribe
I don't really get into that hole oh
they don't I don't have that launcher
whatever like
again oh no we got that one hargit to
need five dollars Super Chat Ubisoft
said AC red so Japan is an RPG during
the show disappointing this one should
be like Mirage again yeah I guess we
talked that to death and then hopefully
it has a little bit of both
um
our man three five six I might get Skull
and Bones I have a couple of people on
the panel let's call them bones
yeah Dragon heart yobi remember for 15
months hashtag peace love life to the
Legends keep up the great work always
with the whole snitch Ryan talk he has
forgotten he he has a forgotten IP in
his Arsenal Socom or get with valve and
bring another Counter-Strike your move
yeah then we have THX 1138 five dollar
Super Chat Sony historically has moved
90 of his first party this generation
ratchet delayed gt7 delayed uh forbidden
West delayed returnal delayed Sackboy
multiplayer and God of War question
question 2023 and Last of Us and Last of
Us sorry
I haven't seen your Take On The Last of
Us Part One it's nowhere near the level
of the other third party or the third
person games it's okay now it's been
patched up but it okay dude it released
in the worst shape I've ever seen ever a
Sony product release wow abysmal I mean
there's videos of that you like the
video Yeah day one even or not did I say
Last of Us yeah yeah you said last of us
what were we talking about the other one
I meant the motorbike one I'm sorry oh
Dave it's gone
sorry Company stock just went down like
yeah
no no no no last no no not last of us I
apologize day's gone released in very
poor I can just see if we so happened to
have like someone from uh
generic I left after three plus hours
slate three plus now shut up
Ragnarok won't get delayed breath of the
wild two is out in 2023 are you saying
big link is in the street big don't let
it happen again big links
and we got hargit to need 20 love Super
Chat AC SEO collection
it's in the a whole bunch of codes for
Assassin's Creed games shout out to you
Harvey for the AC SEO collection Black
Flag then we also have Odyssey the
ultimate edition
Unity oh dude brother Unity
now it's it's 66 and it yo Unity really
Unity like much like days gone was a
broken game at once
but what it was trying to do differently
the multiplayer stuff the the way you go
up you scale up buildings and scale down
um just to added animations for going up
and down like buildings they really did
a lot with that and it didn't get its
love because it was kind of broken and
they also released Rogue the same day
which is stupid
um although Rogue didn't get it far
better than Unity right by far as in
terms of the quality of the the
playability of the product for sure okay
um but Unity go back to Unity now yeah I
need to go back to it like because I I
start I remember the reviews everything
was so broken I guess that was what I
was expecting it was horrible to play
yeah I didn't do it I didn't do it yeah
and and and send to get to Syndicate got
a bad Shake too because that's when
people people were not they were done
with that part of the formula and they
wanted what we got in AC Origins but
Syndicate is great man so good yeah so
thank you hargeet and we are caught up
I posted something in the chat for you
guys they announced that Mirage is only
going to be 49.99
it's rated for adults only it's rated
for adults only that's awesome that's
some news for some news
[Laughter]
you know back out in the news you know
what I'm saying and um
what happened we missed one we missed a
Super Chat no oh we missed the the
PlayStation redesign no no that's the
final one
I just changed the order up because we
are ghosts there and I wanted to get
going I know you have bars I know this
is my this is quick um Yes Man on patch
1.6 is out the edge Runner update and a
lot of new stuff going on obviously Edge
full disclosure so yeah I know you know
I'm saying I did get a chance to go out
I was invited to the premiere for what
was it the Netflix series the anime
series so you get to like the two
episode kind of thing pretty cool I
really enjoyed it had a good time there
but I wanted to talk about
um the actual update itself you know
what I'm saying as far as his running
content you know the weapons couple of
quests that's related to anime stuff
transmog finally in the game which you
know huge for the community
um little man 60 friends PS 50 frames
per second so finally Siri Xbox series
as getting the 60 frames per second jump
that it didn't get before and then um
for me personally cross progression you
know what I'm saying between all the
platforms so I'm trying to do that with
the steam deck my Xbox all that good
stuff and then the final thing which was
huge was um the phantom Liberty DLC
announcement and obviously Johnny
silverhand is going to return and the
big part about it no passion support so
next gen quote-unquote only and just
want to get thoughts this is just open
Forum you know me personally I just get
my balls up quick I'm excited you know
me me personally I really felt like yes
they got dragged and rightfully so we we
know city project red situation we've
we've talked about it at nauseam and it
paid me I was in King situation not to I
just refused to play I didn't want to
play in that state I wanted to wait
until the next Generation patch I fired
it up recently man that's a gorgeous
looking game it's a gorgeous looking
game like I really was like wow I'm glad
I kind of waited and then to me the
other thing I wanted point out is how
their admission of the past generation
when it comes to the AI the algorithm of
the police system and how certain things
kind of held them back and there's a
part of me that is a little excited
about this generation being only and
only thing I'm sad is that they're
saying that Phantom literally will only
be the last that's it they're not making
any more content so I'm assuming an ACG
could probably confirm but deny whether
or not all development after that point
is going to be for the next butcher game
you know what I'm saying and and maybe
that's the situation because there's a
part of me that wanted some of like I
wanted them to get blood and wine
treatment you know what I'm saying right
you know what I'm saying because I love
the world I love the concept but I'm
biased towards sci-fi and all that stuff
you know so look I'm pulling for them
that was just my thoughts but I'm just
curious what anybody thought about it is
there's or some people like that it's
too late the bridges burnt and I'm good
so whatever uh get attic you ready
I think that
hopefully
I've never felt like CD projekt Red was
out to get anyone I feel like they fell
behind a lot of red tape and a lot of
political stuff and
stuff just got out of hand I'm hoping
that they learned from that lesson
because if we've seen anything as long
as you make good games if Witcher 4
comes out hitting
hey for people like cyber what like you
know and that's for the the vast
majority people obviously there's going
to people as long as the game's good
pretty much we're going here in a couple
years and be like remember when they
made that cyberpunk game that just
completely flocked like homie didn't
flop but you get what I'm saying it's
like really buggy
um I I just hope that they learn from it
I hope that they don't think well now we
know ways not to to to Really uh do the
things that we did I just hope they
learn from it and just like look like
you know we've been humbled yeah yeah
and I hope that the management that made
the decisions realize that is it worth
rushing a product out when we took so
much of a hit because we rushed that
product that when maybe an extra year
would have had the game doing what it
was supposed to good point and maybe
it's a learning lesson for the industry
look at cyberpunk as an example ACG I'm
very curious about your thoughts about
this
I think I'm the only one first of all
that like the guy in Syndicate I'm
looking at your chat
[Applause]
TV was just way too sing-song in her
voice I think I also pick up on voice
actresses and actors who are repetitive
they're in a lot of games so Troy
Baker's Troy Baker As Troy Baker yeah
right and nothing against him but that
what's happening is the audio director
should force him it and and they did
that by the way with uh The Last of Us
he even talked about how he thought he
was given his all and Neil druckman was
like dude you're not even you're not
even one tenth of the way there yet I
thought that was awesome even though I'm
not a big fan of them so with cyberpunk
um
past generation continues to get
hammered and it's sad and it's
unfortunate my dislike and issues with
uh CDP are are vastly Beyond any kind of
excuses and I um the fake the fake demos
um the the way they released it the the
behind the scenes Shenanigans
um I I certainly won't hold Witcher
accountable though and I don't think
that that makes any sense too
um a car car lines have bad lemon car
lines sometimes where you're like man
this car is just you know you hear about
it don't buy the 2012. uh for CD Pro uh
for for cyberpunk itself
um I'm done and I don't want to see
anything from them I'm cyberpunk I would
like to see them do number two because
the original cyberpunk has far too many
issues with lack of immersion this is a
RPG one of the most widely known widely
cared for RPGs you can't even sit down
yeah and they miss that that has nothing
to do with forced that's a lack of care
and a lack of understanding CD uh PR has
the money from Cog or good old games
sorry yeah right
had more than enough money to figure out
their [ __ ] and they didn't and that is
directly their hubris it's directly all
of their their issues there internally I
will not hold Witcher 3 accountable nor
a new cyberpunk I would never hold that
accountable but I am done with this one
and I think it's because I know unless
they suddenly add immersion right which
I just have never seen somebody do uh
that game in and of itself is not
drawing me back uh I might do the DLC
but I will really know what I I will
know what to expect and that's that it's
pretty much a shooter with very little
lack of care for the IP and this is
somebody who likes the IP I'm a big fan
of cyberpunk Ip what I would like to see
is Microsoft make a Shadow run first
person shooter game
like Deus Ex the rumor for a while was
that you know Deus Ex might try to out
cyberpunk cyberpunk I think Shadowrun is
the only IP that probably can and
Microsoft has the the foot for it
um guys I just I really have an issue
with our behind the scenes stuff it's
it's something that in 25 years in like
game industry and following it and I
mean following it I've never ever seen
what happened it's black-hearted stuff
that happened and sorry I'm speaking no
I know I don't want to get you I don't
know you're speaking because you were on
my podcast and I remember you were like
let's reconfigure this conversation I
don't reconfigure yeah uh that's my
personal thoughts
um but Witcher phenomenal game
phenomenal game so I won't hold anything
no no the question I have is like when
you say the behind the scenes stuff is
it is it like Management in charge or is
it stuff develop development-wise it
also bothers you uh development wise it
bothers me not I'm not gonna say Joe
Blow the texture artists
and I do also want to say something that
is going to make a lot of people unhappy
but I don't care about political
correctness sometimes developers don't
have ability it happens in a team you
get a great team and your second
stringer's in they're not as good as
your first string you're not saying that
happened I'm saying that management
needs to look at strengths and
weaknesses and decide that but what I am
talking about is the behind the scenes
that happen for probably eight months
prior and that those behind the scenes
were so bad that when I finally did get
offered a code even though they were the
ones who wanted me to do special stuff I
refused it because I was like whatever
is going on is so in it is such a
reflection of of the problematic state
of this game that remember few games get
released and removed from a store afro
samurais is your friggin partner right
now and they got removed from the store
additionally Next Generation I get it
they're trying to say that uh AI was
magically held back we've seen AI that
was spectacular that could at least
spawn cops and by the way modders have
spawned cops so when you try to tell me
that your developer can't make it spawn
cops correctly but modders have fixed it
I have a very
sometimes you almost want them to say
less if that makes sense okay and and so
I will play the DLC most likely I might
review it but um
in and of itself that game is uh a spot
that I don't want to return to it's uh
it's hard to describe
Master Chief Collection I tell everybody
they're like should you buy it and I'm
like no still even even if they fixed it
don't reward it imagine Mario imagine a
Mario game
imagine Mario
can you imagine what happened and we
held Last of Us not Last of Us days gone
I don't want you to get the hell days
gone accountable we should hold CD
projekt Red I do not lift them up above
others like a lot of people do just
because of Witcher because Witcher one
and two sorry guys weren't the greatest
games
[Music]
that's why you know when it comes to it
like the damage has been on it's like I
just hope they learned from a bag
because they do and I think everybody
will even internally guys there's going
to be a dude named Steve who's like no
okay there's got to be a guy named Steve
at every company guys are we really
gonna do this yeah
are we really gonna do what you guys are
doing because this is horrible and
hopefully the managers are listening to
that and hopefully the other developers
are listening and saying you know what
we shouldn't do this and I think they
will I think and to your point maybe
that is maybe that plays into the part
of the decision you know I'm
disappointed about there now being more
and more content them say hey this is
that one and that's it as far as family
for now for now and maybe hold off yeah
let's see what up also they also taught
everybody else because I'm telling you
within a week a game coming out I was
having developers say we do not want to
cyberpunk people that is unheard of by
the way I have never seen that kind of
psychological impact in other teams and
they were in the podcast yeah we do not
want to cyber and that to me taught the
entire industry a little bit too
delays you can bet we're seeing delays
because yes
for sure
yeah and it's like I said man uh I think
they'll be fine uh I think that the
studio learned from its mistake uh you
know it costs some cyberpunk cyberpunk
could have been a franchise and I don't
think they're going to visit that I I
think that I I think they after they do
that DLC I'd be very surprised that they
revisit site well that's what they call
it yeah well
um
one
they're gonna they put in a lot of bread
in this and they're getting out the door
dude just like I don't care what state
it is you gonna fix it later get it out
the door right now I need a boat
why they gotta
get them why is it always got to be a
boat
one of the most realistic shows of
wealth because they lose money every day
that is the perfect example I need a
boat yeah I need a boat for no reason
but that's how they do it they're not
like us they don't go buy a nice car no
they go buy a boat they want to show
they want to floss a golf club anyway
um
I don't believe they learned anything
at all because everybody was bitching
and moaning excuse me sorry Sunday
um everybody was you know crying and
screaming
and still brought it yeah I stood on my
square and said until they get that
patch yeah I'm not playing it I saw
people oh this game is horrible you know
so why are you making a video
oh cause you want to be part of the
whole meter yeah it's like people paying
ten thousand dollars in Diablo and then
complaining about Diablo it's it's it's
dismantality of I gotta play it okay
[Laughter]
I don't care
for the game until it was how I wanted
it because my my money has value you
know I work very hard so when when the
patch showed up I did just like I said
and I went out right and I got it no
doubt all right now this next patch is
even better
it fixed you know some PlayStation 5
stuff and fixed some series X stuff it
fixed some um some Series S stuff man
the little man is out in the streets
but what it did what it did do to put a
hard line in your face
step up to the Next Generation yeah
all right so I don't care if some
modders can go spawn police
I don't care about that let them keep
spawning all the police and holding on
the dead old Hardware if they choose do
that over here
you're gonna have to step up okay you're
gonna have to if you want the shingles
and the shiny stuff you are going to
have to get over here so I like that I
like them forcing you forward you you
don't got all that you don't got nothing
it's nothing for you I like that
um they will never learn
at all they've done this same mistake
with every game and what they say city
project red is the best because they
gave us wine and cheese
DLC is free because they messed you over
so bad they had to give it to free they
they chose to sell it to you so the
reason why they're telling you right now
there's no DLC nothing extra and see it
for for cyberpunk is because later on
when they revisit it they're gonna sell
it to you I mean give you away anything
people forget people forget Witcher 3
was kind of broken that long it broke it
like it and the combat is still terrible
it was um
I'm just saying I'm just saying y'all
keep
putting people in spaces you keep
looking at a leopard and wanting it to
be a bunny rabbit it is a leopard all
right so it's not going to change the
spots it's going to be exactly who they
are and they're going to continue to do
the same exact things because you
continue to do the same exact things so
shout out to them for giving you a patch
shout out to them for continue to fix
the broken game they shipped that you
paid for that you ended in its broken
state that you went back to
because the patch is at 60 frames they
are doing their job so I love it I I
love to see all the backtracking now you
know in hindsight
I do yeah he was doing it so I like it
um it's how I wanted it I didn't take
like I told you before yeah you stood on
your Square on that Final Fantasy 7
didn't launch yet I feel like you're
scared I respect it uh sorry if I didn't
get your thoughts
yeah I mean to me it's like it's that
is that cautionary tale man this this
game will will never ever live up to the
expectation that it had before it came
out it just it won't happen it is
forever marred and you know and like
like Carrick said I think they're best
bet to go back to it is the second one
and doing it right I think for me where
it disappointed me in that same I
haven't really played it yet I got it at
launch with the intention of playing it
when I saw everything that was going on
I was like oh I guess I'm not playing
this now yeah
and um so that was it and then you know
when the when the patches and stuff
would come out like I just don't have
the time to sit and play it and honestly
I may end up playing it on Steam deck
because it's weird
yeah so but to tell you the truth like
looking at I was excited for this game
because I thought it was the way they
talked about it was like oh my God
they're gonna integrate like all of the
quote unquote like rules of cyberpunk
right
um they were gonna integrate it into the
game and the gameplay in a way that felt
like you were living out that fantasy
right that's kind of the fantasy they
sold this on right I remember when you
went to see the game at at E3 Cog and
you came back you were like I've never
seen anything like this before and and
to back to carrick's point it was like
that wasn't you know
exactly and that was that was very much
an orchestrated thing that wasn't what
was happening
um even you know in the best version of
the game which was the PC version it
just wasn't quite that so to me it's
like they they sort of they they really
really over promised on what the scope
of this would be and ultimately I think
that you know looking at back of what
people said about the game who finished
it and played it was like it feels like
it's a great RPG it is not
transformative in the way they sold it
as being and so that to me is where I
kind of like oh my feelings on it are
are are are negative in that regard I'm
still going to take the time out to play
it at some point but it really based on
some of it was expectation sure because
the Witcher really The Witcher 3 was was
was like World killing once it you know
it got out there and just the density of
that world yeah the density of the world
in a lot of ways is kind of unparalleled
when you think about just the story
lines in in which did you say Witcher 3
oh yeah in Witcher yeah like the density
of the world the storyline how live that
world feels how everything feels
interconnected in terms of like this
even the smallest my new Side Story
thing feels like it it doubles back onto
the bigger story it it's really special
in that way and I think a cyberpunk Mr
Mark in that way so that's disappointing
to me so I would like to see them take
another crack at it and really do what
they promised
um I think the next iteration of Witcher
is going to be great and I but I I do
think
in the way that The Witcher wasn't it's
it's a little bit too late for this game
so fix it as much as you can give that
that free DLC that one and be done with
it and move on to the next stuff and
just be sure that you've taken the
lessons learned and don't ever do that
again because all you got to say this
about this people yeah
we said it every game they drop I think
what bothers me most too is that when
you look at it like you you know the
devs look do you know the devs knew full
well they had no business releasing that
game on PS4 and Xbox One the devs new
full well that game was not going to be
ready that's what I'm saying so that's
what bothers me because remember when
when the discourse started when the free
game first came out people attacking the
devs and stuff like that and it's like
dude think about it did they really have
they knew what they were releasing
obviously right they didn't have a
choice they can't say no we refuse to
release the product you know we have we
have Masters to to to to to sort of uh
Andrew to so you know it's just that
aspect of it that bothers me but again
the the company today I don't think is
is not worth you know that this is how
how crazy the cyberpunk thing has been
for them that the company just isn't
worth as much now as it was before yeah
right yeah so you know really you have
to focus on your your subsequent
products to live up to the ability that
you know that you have because the thing
is
they did Witcher 3. they can make that
game they can make that type of game
with that level of scope that level of
detail and even take it Beyond it's just
gonna be you have to understand that if
you strive for that again this is a
10-year process like you have to really
understand what it takes to build that
you have to look at the rock star model
and be like look what Rockstar does
Rockstar rockstars Games come out when
they come out when they say it's ready
but they have the cash in the cash to do
something right and inside and then CD
doesn't have that anymore I don't agree
red has a box they have Gog they do have
Gog they have one yeah and they've now
admitted that that does feedback into it
and they don't need to go on an apology
tour like a freaking comedian who said
something yeah right so they do yeah
I mean maybe they do come to my house no
apologize
about that Carrick like money wise
you're right Gog is a big deal and they
you know again that no DRM when people
love that
um yeah they they can do it but they
have to take the time
um we'll see if that's the case
hopefully they learn the lesson other
people have learned lessons from them
yes
some other people yeah other people I
think I think it's also caused declarity
in you know I don't know any other way
to say I just don't really too much
about but worry about PR so I'm just
gonna yeah political correctness but I
think it's also shine Delight on
reviewing yes and
um I saw a lot of people saying one
thing and then going on their own
apology tours on podcasts and rolling
back their reviews and being like well
maybe I shouldn't have said blah blah
it's like listen if you can't tell me
after 40 hours of playing a game what
your score is then then you shouldn't
review it or just call it Impressions
call it Impressions
that's a model that laws give me that
and I think we're starting to see
um well maybe we're not but we are I do
know from some people I talk to where
it's definitely causative Clarity even
from consumers going okay okay on a
review I need to really remember that
bugs are not called features that means
and and so it's possible that somebody
didn't get as many bugs or somebody got
way more and and maybe it's best and I'm
a reviewer so it would behoove me to say
just watch mine but I don't believe that
it doesn't even make sense to me instead
watch a couple and then if if a person's
on the PC if the person's on a console
they have more bugs there more bugs
there keep a keep a good eye out and I
think that like you said uh Cog that it
is a watershed moment for not for
consumers even point so that people can
sit down and go okay this does happen in
an electronic product it's not the same
as a car if your car randomly exploded
every 30 feet it would be a crap car
right
um but it's not the same thing but I
think we can all together even
influencers have changed even you guys
have changed because of cyberpunk
because like your thoughts maybe you
liked Witcher 3 and this one came out
and now you're sitting back going all
right maybe there's a thought process
it's a unfortunate and it's one of the
most costly if not the most video game
costly uh teaching lesson absolutely
absolutely maybe Xbox One release would
have been higher
places man yeah yeah you don't want to
share that right cyberpunk shares a lot
of spots with some really crappy people
on the podium where you're like I just
went first place in the world's
crappiest race and that's the place
where they want to be I'm just glad
final point I'm just glad I stood on my
Square I took the kid approach after I
heard the reviews I saw your review ACG
and it was kind of like it's the
Godfather look how they Master good boy
I don't want to see it like that because
I just like it doesn't I had to save my
Italian's King it does not exist until
it gets to I hear that it's it's safe to
come outside
look I heard Cog say I wanted to say
want to say something positive about it
it does at times look
at times it if I don't walk it looks
phenomenal when I move Things Fall Apart
right does that make sense it's almost
like a picture on the internet of a girl
you're gonna date and you go and you're
like that ain't necessarily the truth
there's something about cyberpunk that
at times is so gorgeous and so
um emotive to me as a fan of cyberpunk
and wanting to play role-playing games
and seeing this world and going whoa and
then you know people fall from the sky
or whatever
it does man it's I get why people love
the look because it's uh it's something
special at at times yeah I'm trying not
to even go too far I want I want um Deus
Ex to out uh
absolutely bro absolutely and I think
they can yeah
man let them do it man bring back Warren
Specter
because he lost Bioshock you guys heard
about that our system yeah System Shock
three's IP left him now yeah hey sweet
let's go let's get to this last topic so
I saw a Super Chat there or because
um what do we have we do yeah uh
actually let me see hold on
not too many okay
I think the cyberpunk world has much to
has too much promise to die with just
one expansion cdpr should look at this
learn then after Witcher 4 come back to
the world of cyberpunk yes definitely in
a new game what's your full gonna come
out broken just like all others
[Laughter]
[Music]
we need a culture change for rushing to
embargoes
yeah I mean a lot of again everybody's
kind of the race to the race to the
bottom when it comes to who gets stuff
first and you know whatever time
allocated for yourself yes and when it
when the Embargo is in relation to when
you get it even though let's be honest
people had this for two weeks but
whatever yeah yeah
no excuse sorry bro I Gotta Throw Some
truth out there because I'm getting
really tired of the here's my language
I'm trying to continually control what I
say but I'm getting really tired of
people coming up with all of these other
excuses and I'm sorry they had it for
two weeks sorry I'm getting mad this is
where but God [ __ ] your truth Dutch darn
it this kind of stuff this is the same
crap the same myths that I'm constantly
talking about in reviews you'll hear
somebody say oh day one means the game
sucks day one embargo no it doesn't I
had stated to K2 for two weeks was that
game a master class no we have a crap
games that are out for a long time and
we have games that are out day one for
embargoes it has nothing to do with the
Embargo it has to do with the Damned
company and when the game is ready and
what they're releasing it does it's such
a small deal when it comes to the
reviews or it comes to the timing the
game is broken live with it sit in your
stink and accept that it sucked and
you're just gonna have to be a man about
it because this kind of stuff blaming
anything else has nothing to do with
that the majority of those don't have
this issue it has to do with that game
in particular being unacceptable upon
releasing you need to suck it up it was
removed from the damn store yeah that's
like sorry yeah bro Samurai too was the
only game like sorry
that makes me really angry what store
was it removed from oh Lord oh yeah
it was removed from the PlayStation
store because they don't like to give
back money I know
it was another entire thing where the
companies themselves hopefully learned a
lesson on how to do refunds yeah
Microsoft had no problem they said I
know you don't like the game there's
your money back we don't care sorry
let's move on
he's been waiting for this opportunity
it's yours continue time time one kid
because I know what he doing
we saw it at the main event oh God the
combo traffic shout out to King shout
out to you I'm addict so um look we got
two aspects of this um shout out to King
my my topic ain't part of this okay so
well I'll just bet you it's already five
o'clock yeah
it's not the same thing but God bless oh
okay no more PS5
okay so PS5 so these new PS5 has been
totally redesigned inside uses less
power shout out to Time Warner and The
Verge shout out to Austin Evans who did
the tear down revise kind of broke down
just I'll give you a quick synopsis new
smaller motherboard smaller heatsink SSD
enclosure change and new PS5 uses less
power during games and then it comes to
I believe his um estimation is that this
is I said Austin Everett Evans and I
quote Sony make almost everything
including motherboard and internal
packaging to make it lighter and almost
certainly cheaper for them since
everyone's on Twitter and they shrink
your wallet at the same time
arrives just as Sony has hiked its PS5
prices outside of the US Sony's
increases PS5 prices at UK Europe Japan
China Australia Mexico and Canada and
then to Kings news which is solely long
time PlayStation Hardware Chief to
retire next month so the 60 year old and
forgive my pronunciation
Ito who led the engineering for both the
PS4 and PS5 is retiring according to
Sony's Communications manager the
responsibility of the platform is now
going to be now led by um senior senior
vice president Hideki licino and lashina
was promoted to that role in March 2021
so they kind of give a life story of of
Ito and his involvement it was down with
the increase of the psvr headset the PS4
Pro and Sony's latest PS5 console so he
is stepping down so this is Kings and
addicts tablet but King is here and uh
oh here comes Buck
well look here Cal Polk
here we go they done did a new
redesigning and trimmed up everything
everything is inside the box is
different
even the price
one thing I don't understand is how come
that darn thing is so dag Gone Big still
so you weren't happy with your own
internals and I mean the outside of the
shower give me what I pay for
I paid for a big PlayStation with all
the big Parts it went inside shrunk my
man Parts yo
but left the outside the same now to me
that sounds like a little little hung
Swagger these dudes is out here
bamboozling
leading you astray I'm running the buck
so
you know who don't want no part to this
we don't want to put this out
oh so the engineer
on this he said you know what I helped
redesign it I hope trim down stuff I
thought I was going to pass the savings
on the consumer
all right comes up he said I didn't sign
up for that oh that's not where I was
trying to do so this is I was trying to
give the money back it's a recession oh
so I was trying to help out the populace
not your pockets
I see right now
he not gonna be around for the next one
oh this is your conclusion be your next
one is
practices
or I told you it was something fishy in
there I told you it was a redesign
you're supposed to save you get smaller
you're safe no buddy
it raised the price and you gonna pay
for it so there's a sucker born every
day I'm looking right at you
both peepers upon you
don't buck up on me boy
thank you Lord bucks so clearly your
thought process is you know the the the
the the the the engineer what the chief
Engineers he was completely disgrunted
with this decision to to raise the
prices how else would he leave now oh
okay he had a chance to leave before
after
I'm done I'm finished I'm out of here he
said you know what I want to give
something back to society I'm gonna trim
this thing up this thing is a monster
just
crazy it's crazy you know we can lower
the price he said who the hell are you
to tell us
[Laughter]
begin
I do I do appreciate I do appreciate you
doing all the hard work but I know for
nothing but don't you worry about it cow
poke
we got jobs over here for you
yes interesting reasoning on uh why
things played out the way they did um
yeah ACG so maybe we could get some uh
balance to the force here
um I mean your thoughts
it's like I love Lord of the Rings so
having like you know the I am Mordor
Tower in here is pretty cool but the
fact is is that um it's an ugly
massive
obtuse machine
that plays good games but uh I don't
really care about the internal redesigns
I mean if it improves stuff I think
that's awesome and they should continue
to do so especially with heating I've
this is my third PS3 oh
yeah I I was one I was one of the ones
who had a PS5 die during the review
period and then die a week later after
the review period oh yeah I remember the
reviewers had had systems die
um I don't necessarily have any real
mine's hidden because it's so ugly as in
the wife won't even allow it out and
that's not a lie she's that it doesn't
fit anything it messes up the decor it's
so weird so I have it here
he's telling us something important the
thing about shrinking up stuff
especially on a die shrink you know
sometimes you'll hear Intel on a die
shrink it'll be more expensive but
that's not what they're doing they are
just shrinking up the actual innards and
moving things around it should
technically be cheaper uh so I don't
know what's going on there with the
price and and how that's all worked out
I hope that it doesn't have more issues
because I think the original still has
some some tech issues in particular hard
drives consistently saying you need to
rebuild the database which I still have
people in my Discord toward getting that
anytime they reboot their PS5
I'm just surprised I'm surprised that
they raised the price and I wasn't aware
of this until two a day or so ago where
they where they shrunk it down gotcha I
don't really know what they did probably
heat I would assume you know trying to
figure some stuff
yeah I was a little surprised when they
said smaller heatsink I was like whoa
whoa whoa guys is that really the way we
want to go is that right but uh uh
hopefully all I care about is that
consumers get something that continually
delivers and they don't have to take it
to Sony's 8 000 week long repair period
so
mine took a long time and I knew
somebody at Sony in my time you hear
that he had a guy on the inside I did uh
one of them head guy by the way and it
still took a while to get one repaired
yeah you see that
it uses 10 less energy which is good
somebody says that that's good because
Energy prices are going who the hell and
you said that I just saw it in your chat
if that's true who the hell in that chat
done said that you ain't even got one oh
stop Ryan East oh you even got one
that's so mad you got the only one
that's using the 10 more
messy wow those are only in Australia
when it's hot kid addict your thoughts
on this PS5 redesign
and it's I just think like obviously I I
I'm not anything in the building when it
comes King I got I can't look at you uh
where I don't know beautiful stuff I
don't know
the logistics from the day-to-day
I can't act like I do but to me if
you're making the platform
cheaper
and then you first off you're already
making a profit and now you've you've
manufactured it cheaper throughout the
years and you still increase it in
certain regions
I feel like that's jacked up because
it's just like you know I don't it's
like I said I don't know exactly maybe
they're they're starting to pay priority
on some of these cards like uh like some
of these chips like Microsoft did at the
beginning of the pandemic and maybe
they're passing that that cost on to the
consumer but it to me it's just like
dude like you did it everywhere but
America so it makes me feel like that's
not genuine either so I'm just like
I've I just personally like I'm
speechless like this is for us tasteful
I just I don't know how to word it
anymore like it's called every week
every week we come in here and I feel
like I mean maybe it's just me but I
feel like almost every week to every
other week this bad PlayStation news
what are you doing
he's busy more materials more material
so the less attic has the other front
dots
I mean I think that I just I concur with
everybody like I don't know anything
about how this stuff gets made but you
assume that the moment they put that
console out they're already working on
how to make it cheaper right right how
to make it cheaper for them to
manufacture the moment you put that
first iteration out you're working on
that
um so to me every change that they've
made subsequent to the initial launch of
this console is in service of get
getting parts that are easier to get off
the shelf and making it cheaper and you
know moving stuff around figuring it
figuring out the sort of uh the sort of
physics behind it and figuring out how
to make it more efficient while make it
more cheaper so yeah and to me it only
makes sense that whatever this new build
is is cheaper and it looks bad when
you're talking about raising prices and
and all these other markets right to me
the biggest thing is you don't raise the
price in the in the U.S market because
you have a real competitor in Xbox now
that has that has
said they're not raising the price on
their premium box and it's already
beating you by 200 or 100 something and
whatever changed in with this with their
you know more economic option so it's a
smart thing to do uh
to me
I don't know it just again like addict
said this is always something that feels
a little bit negative right this this
kind of any other day just gets you know
whatever brushed under the under the
couch or whatever the case may be
listen I I will definitely acknowledge
and give you your flowers yeah
before I'll do this
before this is what I'm talking to my
wife she's talking I'm like
but but I just think it is yeah nowadays
is always something like even if it's
minor in a way like you know remember
when Xbox usually just step on the rig
for no reason
yeah and it's just like it's constantly
messing up and tripping over themselves
and PlayStations didn't have to do much
really but just offer the opposite of
what they were offering what they're
doing not do what they're doing and they
would win and it feels like it isn't
that dire here it's not but it there is
constantly something a little bit
negative there isn't you know Again Last
of Us Part one came out and most people
you know find it great and a lot of the
conversation around the seventy dollars
kind of died down or whatever the case
may be and you know hopefully Ragnarok
does the same for them but it's just
when it comes to the business of
PlayStation and what people who are in
the PlayStation ecosystem are used to uh
expecting from PlayStation and
constantly having this positive message
it's not that anymore it's not that
anymore it's just so you know again this
isn't a huge deal but the fact of the
matter is they've raised prices kind of
everybody's prices immediately right
when they announced it and then all of a
sudden you know for this to be the case
where they they figured out how to make
it cheaper more efficient why did you
just not eat that like you know do you
understand what I mean like well I'll
jump right in I mean to me it's just uh
indicative of of the leadership mindset
and Direction and this is a this is a
mix don't matter yeah it doesn't matter
what's what Jim Ryan is showing me
Optics does not matter what matters is
the bottom line and then he get in
Revenue he turned the European division
around you know and now the focus has
been in the countries that they have I
have to give kickness the timing of this
announcement and con the timing of they
finding the way to cheapen the skew and
make the parts much easier you know what
I mean and more efficient and course
friendly to in conjunction with the the
price raising in conjunction with now
more availability of PlayStation 5S to
ship it sounds like a corporate
Financial move it sounds like a scaled
rollout and they're not hiding it that's
the funny thing it's kind of in plain
sight so that's the thing that's
interesting me and to just your points
off it's it's surprising because only
because it's like I don't wanna I don't
want to use the word arrogance but it
it's no it's definitely it's Brazen in
the factory there has been
so much again not I would say like these
these what's the depth that's the bad
but we had about death by a Thousand
Cuts it's just it's always something it
feels like it's always this little thing
oh okay now he's got something you got
to pay for the you know the update here
and you know okay you don't got
technically you don't got smart delivery
and now we got to pay for this you know
to utilize the PS5 feature and okay now
you're raising the price up and
ingredients okay now you're doing this
and okay seven dollar games okay it just
starts to add up but what to their
credit they have this amazing cachet
that they're able to survive this and
generally to your points huh all it
takes is now let's show the Lord Last of
Us trailer look at the Fidelity here's
the garden one Ragnarok look at the
trick this is what we do and that's it
my only concern Mr King's Point at some
point if you keep doing these type of
things right especially in these other
regions now that let's be honest we're
not affected you know what I'm saying
but these all other regions are
seriously affected where Xbox is behind
and now it's on Xbox to capitalize right
to show the value that they have in
their system to try to close the gap and
it's going to be interesting to me you
know I'm saying I'm not saying as a
result that oh they automatically lost
the generation they're clearly still
doing well they just showed in Europe
they've overtaken the switch so I think
Jim Rogers thing is like yo I'm a bottom
line guy I don't care about your
feelings I could tell you Generations
one minute and now we doing this next
minute I can tell you about yo the
prices and this that the third you know
we made record profit but hey yo because
of the inflation now we have to do you
know like it's he just he's just outside
with it it's a true like like ACG
alluded to you know the Sean Laden era
and the comments that was done right
that and I've had this conversation with
Colin and kind of even admits like get
ready this is a difference so even the
live service about there is a focus and
there's a difference between confidence
and ego confidence is silent you can be
confident yourself walk into a room
you're confident nobody even knows but
you're still confident it's completely
yes what Sony used to be with with Sean
Laden and the confidence would they talk
about an indie game or whatever but it
what happens with Jim as it comes across
his ego and it won't take a long time
just because she doesn't hit you doesn't
mean she loves you
no way and what we're getting now is
this thing where they continue to do
these kind of things especially raising
the price I'm sorry it does affect me I
own a PlayStation 5. it affects me
because my friends that are outside of
the United States may have a harder time
buying it in a worldwide you know
depression unless you're in China which
they just lift up their money due to Bad
Mortgages I don't think
that Sony thinks about it that's true
but at the same time
um I'm just going to say that at some
point I would assume other people will
within the company there's always and
yeah there and and I'm just wondering
when someone else is going to say hey
guys man we got to turn
this around a huge shout out to their PR
who used to be very difficult and very
um old Scott old style in in how they
handle things if they've really stepped
it up so there's a huge internal change
in how they handled people like myself
covering games or what have you I think
the big company can change but um I
think also they'll probably give them a
long time to fail before they replace
him and I'm not calling for his
replacement correct they will you know
and they should because you're right Cog
I don't know if people realize this same
thing with Don matrick we all we all
love to hate him Don Matrix actually had
a lot of success at EA in Prior a ton
and there's a reason why people wanted
him there the reason why the connect was
sold in the original Xbox one was
because the connect sold like hot well
yeah so it made sense as a business yes
any of us would have said that would
have been like whoa
so I think it'll take a while but death
by a Thousand Cuts does kill you yeah
eventually and I we're gonna get there
at some point yeah even if it's an
internal Suite yeah if it keeps me a nut
we ain't ever getting more Jim Riot on
this podcast because I imagine Jim Ryan
on this podcast
I mean Jim Ryan won't talk to kind of
funny like it's not gonna happen like I
don't think that's that's not who he is
well I mean to be honest PlayStation
don't really talk to us in general into
anybody yeah
that I mean to me they come in here
look at the end of the day there is
value by you know as far as from the
financial aspect the teams incorporate
for those accomplishments and sometimes
the financial team they win out they win
a lot of these arguments right and if
he's continued to make hit his
deliverables and showing if it means
remastering I love this guy you know
what I'm saying and it's showing that
they're still winning and he can sit
there and say look we just won UK we're
just doing this we're the number one
console here now we got and he can
survive that you know and it's gonna
it's gonna be Bobby Connick can support
survive
yeah right yeah he getting a check and
he disappearing he lets you know so it's
just interesting with big corporate but
that's all I wanted to say this is very
really I really want to take a bow okay
I really want to I really want to say to
all the PlayStation dudes that was
coming at me before you used to light up
my Twitter line
what you saw me doing this right here
yes
that definite sound that nothing
that I hear I'm not hearing anything I
don't hear y'all anymore
I don't beat y'all back and now y'all
afraid see he's got a chip on his
shoulder oh yeah yeah which I get but at
the same time
I think we're all we have to come to the
conclusion where it just hurts everybody
gaming yeah oh no what I mean is 70
forever for your games is one thing we
were all like what and then like Cog was
saying and I forgot and I can't believe
I forgot because I was always
complaining about it is the nickel and
dime kind of upgrade thing PS4 PS5 oh
here's ten bucks and then you get this
it's I want people
even if it's like and I like my
PlayStation I have great games on it I
want more people to get into it and so
it's funny to joke but at the same time
it's actually pretty depressing for me
at times when I sit back I talk to a
friend who's like dude I can't afford
for example cyberpunk one of my friends
that's all the money he had and he
bought it regardless of my review and I
was like um
and he told he's like dude I'm actually
take this as you will yeah because I
don't get depressed about video games
nothing matters less to me there's Wars
going on that matters
but it was depressing to hear him
because the dude didn't have a lot of
money and he was like
he was like dude I don't have a lot of
money and it's terrible and there's
something about that that even if we all
joke I think we can all agree that like
yeah it's pretty friggin sad that we're
talking about this in the first place
that uh that we're crunching people's
wallets right and I'll say the same
thing if Microsoft raises their prices
but you know what you know what ACG I
say this in joke and I say it in levity
I know you do to to to bring it across
because the the comedic tone will go
further than the service tone I feel
that right true and
I want you all to wake up
um
that part right you got to remove you
got to show the emperor he has on no
clothes you have to show him
because right now he's wearing nicer
clothes because he bought them
yeah he just brought a yacht
um the fact that he
is not him
yeah I know what you mean that's right
he's just the face all right he's the
face he's a he's the face of your ire
right the fact that they could say the
things that they do say with such a
level of arrogance that a matter of
factly you're going to still patreon us
anyway
remember that that level and I got a
second job to get one
I'm such a hypocrite I'm such a
hypocrite
right I'm gonna get uh God of War I'm
such a hypocrite the numbers say with
the number Gamers sit there and talk but
when that trailer come and all that the
Zeitgeist and everybody like ACG they
talk about but when you said people
reviewing it you know what I'm saying
they want the accessing the thing and if
it's it's a whole different energy and I
Gotta Give Sony this they know it I want
to know when I know it I want that I
want that Sunday I want that Sunday when
I do and when I'm able to show show up
and it's the final nail because see
these dudes every week don't understand
they're like damn every week this dude
comes in here with something different
every week and it's been like this for
the past like 18 weeks has been going
committing hit weekly go back and check
yeah I want to talk about
something different next week man it's
almost 5 30. I just want that I just
want that final nail because listen
I'm a Sega boy
ever forget yeah exactly kitchen I
respect it I respect it no now look I
want your games on my box yeah did you
guys see Sega some of the Sega people
traveling around too yeah
yeah check out some twitters you see I'm
seeing some people moving around on
Twitter today talking about visiting
Japan visiting Europe and stuff so I
wonder if some stuff's going on how
about you visit in Seattle
then we got Lucius Augustus remember for
one year two dollars
meanwhile the media is silent while Sony
does this yeah there's not a whole lot
of conversation around I will say this
week I would say I've seen I've seen a
lot of outlets really call out and say
hypocrisy about the whole inadequate
aspect I I have they've gotten negative
a lot of trending on I mean it was it
was it was big it was big I saw some
argument saying oh you know anybody who
uses the ff7 argument is is comparing
apples to oranges I'm like no it's the
same principle the principle the scale
is different but the scale is different
but the principle is the same actually
it's it's worse he said yesterday yeah I
know actually it's worse because you
know they own Call of Duty at that point
when that decision will be made Sony
don't own square unit so it's actually
worse
uh we got to need 10 super chat Xbox
needs to take advantage ship mode most
of the consoles is holiday to markets
outside of the US 90 90 plus percent
Series S over X and make it the equity
of above of approximately 200 hey if you
give me a 200 uh holiday bundle then s
oh and friends and family Game Pass for
like three months that's another thing
we have the game pass family plan
becoming a thing like bro
they're really really giving people a
lot of reasons to jump ship they are
yeah no absolutely
mm-hmm be good
it's awesome yeah we go oh sorry let's
roll this up again I'm sorry
I let you get your balls off I'll let
him get his balls off for a second
he got five minutes
if you got something to do man go ahead
and uh you can go ahead and take off I
don't want to feel like we keep you he's
gonna beat the brakes
my wife I'm in the other room
so it's not even late so this is why I
was doing this whole thing okay go ahead
and take off all right
I sent you to Drake so get your balls up
if you can I'm gonna do the poll while
wait
um look Cog went all the way over to the
packs I'm not taking off I respect
respect this man all righty ladies all
pole with Sony's latest statement
regarding Xbox Call of Duty offer
staying on Playstation three years after
the current Arrangement being inadequate
what do you feel Microsoft's response
should be the choices are
then the Call of Duty offer past three
years to maintain the relationship with
Sony and still profit but yet still
profit by doing so B makes the deal with
Sunni after the current PlayStation uh
Call of Duty agreement ends make game
pass the exclusive home of Call of Duty
or C I don't care switch still is coming
in hot with Call of Duty not on their
platform
salute to everybody a rock chat let's
get the legendary Paris Lily in the
building salute sir should have seen you
out there in Seattle I was hoping I'd
get a chance to to link it with you but
I saw a Kyle and he said the cooking was
great so he has some slander for you but
it was good
no I I know he did man and yeah I wish I
could have come out to pack so there was
some last minute stuff that happened I
couldn't make it out but but we'll do it
no I I just saw you you're having like a
20-hour podcast I couldn't believe it's
still going but I'm assuming you're
you're talking about all this young and
Jim Ryan yes all that nonsense I mean
here's the thing and I've been saying
this all week
this is all business this is all
business the deal is going to go through
of course Jim Ryan is going to posture
and try and get the best deal he
possibly can PlayStation but at the end
of the day like I was in the spaces and
I had a dude that was arguing with me
basically telling me that Microsoft has
to negotiate with PlayStation I'm like
no they don't why PlayStation has not
invested one red nickel into this
acquisition how can someone that's not
purchasing the company for 70 billion
dollars dictate to the company that is
purchasing it for 70 billion dollars if
anything like here's here's the funny
part about all this stuff and I'm sure
you guys have already said this if you
look at everything that Phil Spencer and
Microsoft has said since January it's
been consistent what if they said
differently they've said the entire time
we've given them a generous offer to
keep PlayStation on you know keep Call
of Duty on Playstation right for a
certain amount of time Jim Ryan is the
one that came out he's known this since
January by the way he's the one that's
come out now and said oh no it's a
three-year deal past the current
contract because he realizes we're going
to have to negotiate something with
Microsoft on Microsoft terms if we want
to keep Call of Duty basically going
into the PlayStation 6 era because
that's really what this is all about
right it's the next generation of
consoles so if you look at it that way
Phil Spencer has actually been pretty
generous in saying we're going to give
you time to either negotiate something
with us to keep Call of Duty or develop
your own IP to replace Call of Duty it's
not it's not like they're taking it away
tomorrow it's not going away tomorrow
that's why when I see all here's my
whole thing with Twitter and all the
Outreach that you see let's go nobody
but nobody believes anything that
they're typing when they're outraged
because why you're still going to get to
play Call of Duty on Playstation no
one's taking it from you ultimately I
think Call of Duty stays on Playstation
I just think Microsoft wants something
more than what the current deal entails
that's all it is and the PlayStation one
doesn't want to do that fine it won't be
on there anymore but ultimately what's
going to happen is Call of Duty is going
to be Day One on Game Pass just like
Phil Spencer said right and people are
going to have a choice if you don't want
to buy an Xbox if you don't want to play
on PC if you don't want to Cloud stream
it you can go still spend 70 dollars in
fact and play it on Playstation so I I
don't see what all this outrage is about
because it's gonna happen and honestly
this Activision deal really isn't even
about Call of Duty
it's about the mobile yes
that's that's what it's really about and
if you think PlayStation doesn't see
that gold mine of course they do why do
you think they just did the acquisition
that they did for the studio they want
to invest in that stuff too and since
I'm here and uh King King I see all the
stuff the king says it just makes me
laugh on Twitter
but in your humor is a lot of Truth in
the sense that PlayStation is doing
exactly what Microsoft started back in
2016. they're doing the same exact thing
they just didn't adopt this current
business model until later on so all the
infrastructure you see they're building
up all the studio Acquisitions that
you're seeing they're doing they're
investing in PC now they're investing in
Mobile they are expanding beyond the
console right and that's what I think
people are understanding when they when
they scream about like exclusives and
all this stuff you will still have
console exclusives but PlayStation is
going to say you can play our games on
PC you can play them on mobile you can
stream on cloud we don't care because
it's all about money no good point I got
one question for you um
what's your thought process on the let's
be honest the negative PR hit that you
know sodium is getting as far as the
inadequate verbiage right so do you
think because the nature of this the
deal is this important the scale is that
big we've had a discussion here as far
as well as maybe the thought process is
willing to risk the negative backlash
from you know from the Optics because of
the money involved where the franchise
can end up and the ramifications of the
possibility I agree with you I think
that It ultimately will stay the play
soon but the ramification of the
possibility that it after the three
years or the extension that if there's
no extension of the Call of Duty
franchise yeah I I again this is all
posturing that's all this is because I
think because I think it is in
PlayStation's benefit to object as much
as they possibly can before the deals
officially because of whatever it's a
miracle it does fall through now your
competition doesn't have this key in
their Arsenal that's all this is so if
there's a chance to potentially mix
something just mention this is what you
say man keep commission yeah of course
because because look if my last name was
Ryan I'd be submission too I do the same
exact thing
[Laughter]
salute to you man always a pleasure to
hear from you telling people what you
got going on with you and kind of for
the X guys game attack radio Legends
stuff where you hosting what you doing
what's going on with you brother yeah I
mean that's pretty much it man uh
gamertag radio yeah hey 2005 and uh kind
of funny on xcas and uh there might be a
couple things
okay
it's a little thank you brother for
popping I know thank you for having me
on no doubt dude I had to get you get
you in there real quick so I'll get the
Super Chat that we do got to go we got
to go here we go
we got the rubber knob
five dollar Super Chat morning Lords I
think the issue with Sony is that they
won't get any exclusive Maps mods Etc
and they can't restrict the series X
version anymore they're gonna get all of
that that's the thing the own Microsoft
doesn't need to put nickel and dime them
and Penny pence in that way all the uh
only thing they need is Game Pass
Pro that's it value right there they
don't need to nickel and dime them with
exclusive maps and stuff like that it
doesn't matter Game Pass is the great
equalizer and that's yeah and and and
you're not gonna unless Jim Ryan is like
I'll give you a hundred million dollars
for every player for for every Call of
Duty game we'll give you a hundred
million dollars not to put it on
gameplay
[Music]
International podcast the greatest
reviewer in the modern era right now the
guy who breaks down the science of the
games and you better be knowing about
you step up your sound reviews people
got to step up these sound reviews
because ACG yeah they're exposing a lot
of people that don't really be putting
that sound in the game ACG man my
brother where can I find people find you
what else do you have coconut well
thanks for inviting me as always it's a
blast I I definitely appreciate it um
I'm doing two NDA previews you know the
stupid stuff where you can't even talk
about them I hate that kind of crap like
you can say you're doing something
um doing some reviews coming up here
soon I do also want to thank I saw a lot
of people in the chat that are from the
Channel I want to thank people
especially with YouTube
um absolutely adult rating everything I
do now no cussing no violence wait what
dude yeah 18 videos in the last like
couple days everything's demonicles what
uh Patron mostly like they definitely
helped but um I had to remove the
podcast because the podcast was getting
hammered so often so we had to stop that
put it on Spotify so if you do want to
follow and listen to a podcast we're on
Spotify and and iTunes and all that kind
of stuff but I just want to give a shout
out to the people who do support the
channel by views it doesn't matter if
it's paid or not I definitely appreciate
that but I also want to shout out
somebody who is phenomenal to me because
I ain't the best reviewer writing on
games now I think I've mentioned him
before Seamus but if you guys get if if
anybody's listening you want a reviewer
who I I honestly believe has eclipsed
reviewers to the point to where I'm like
man I'm not even in this I'm like in the
junior high school level that's a huge
phrase from you writing on games is one
of the most phenomenal reviewers doesn't
do a lot and rarely gets games early but
he does he he's we can also you can
script emotion and sound cool you can I
can talk fast yeah but dude I'm telling
you
every time he posts a video it I will
stop every I pretty much unsubscribe the
most and I like his videos hit at like 9
00 p.m or something and he broke down
every Hitman level Wow and his his
ability to to parse out the feeling of
being Hitman is something that
profoundly makes me embarrassed for my
level of coverage like it's that good as
Shannon I've had him on the podcast once
or twice but if you guys he's a smaller
Channel right now send me the info I
would definitely I already get him on
the channel
he is he's fully I'm not and this is not
behind the scenes baseball but he um
sometimes he fights the inner demons
always yeah open to coming on stuff but
he will over time hey guys I'm telling
you there's nobody out there that
deserves a subscription more than that
guy okay and my attention span is not
the best sometimes yeah
I'm just like beated in and I've
listened to his stuff four times and one
time he was describing hitting somebody
with like a brick and hit man from afar
and the way it feels to be like this guy
and I was like I should put my [ __ ] down
now
because yeah that's how good he is
um wow so if you get a chance check him
out uh it's it's just phenomenal and
once again thank you to you guys for
inviting me it's always a blast to come
on it's uh it's hilarious I'm always I'm
always expecting something and we always
go yeah like I didn't know this green
hat leprechaun looking dude that like
that like King is now I've never seen
this guy so when he puts on the green
hat I'm like what is happening at this
particular time everybody comes on my
podcast and they say that and this is
the only podcast where I'm like I have
no clue where we're gonna go but it's
gonna be fine appreciate it appreciate
it appreciate you brother and the thing
about you that I want to give you your
flowers I mean you know not only is for
your stature as big as you are I love
how you uplift others and I love you
know you you don't bloviate about
yourself and you're one of our guys we
think you like you're one of the
greatest I appreciate that and and your
your candidness your honesty you know
you don't hold back you speak your truth
and I love what you do for the community
it's always a pleasure that you get a
chance to link and just have these
gaming discussions we can agree disagree
but it's respectful it's fun and I get I
don't know that quick I don't know where
hatke
Xbox expansion pass great to have more
Luke in the building Lord addict where
can I find people find what you got
going on sir finally getting something
to eat talk to you guys next week oh the
hunger kitchen
yeah two hours passed by eating Prime
all right all right
Lord welcome back sir thank you yeah big
shout out thanks to everybody who got at
me and uh just wished me yeah
and then and uh yeah you'll find me
doing what I always do I gotta go to
work hey that's what I'm going to do now
make sure we get the super chat on the
way out we finished Lord King alleged
returns they were mad that the show
started without you they wanted to
boycott us until you came but we're glad
you came to save the show thank you
thank you Michael Jackson
foreign
like randomly he will hit me in the DMs
like with a random yes random yes and so
um I really love this dude really dude
um I really like uh his effort because
if you watch his program uh
he's been here for four hours
and he only let like one person yeah I
know oh yeah I'm surprised I can't do it
I'm dying
I really respect this guy and I really
think about all the stuff that he does
so you know he he's blowvating about the
other guy but his stuff is phenomenal
stuff too so if you're not uh subscribed
to him or if you don't know about his
channel which I don't know where the
hell you're at uh please go there and
please check out his review he did one
and um the Alan Wake one I think Alan
Wake especially check out his shorts
he's been doing shorts
but also uh I love solve yeah and um any
time that you know one of us is missing
from uh the show yeah it's a big voice
yeah we lose a little something on each
right so uh you know those super chats
don't get done without you yeah so
um everybody that showed up we had uh a
900 plus almost a thousand people
watching football game everybody that
showed up on us on a Sunday yeah this is
a crazy wood football going on so yeah
thank you guys for and I hope I gave you
something entertaining
um remember if you're not subscribed to
COG please go subscribe to them right
now
he is literally James Brown
honest working man in the business
try your brother yeah you guys you guys
make it easy for me and um got a good
team around us Future's bright I'm
excited to talk about games doing that
fun stuff more things cooking also I'm
gonna get these last two I think we'll
be listening we out we gotta yeah hold
on a second we got uh tenet over with
the 50 Super Chat thank you so much just
woke up in Australia to see you online
you know we going too long with
Australia
Jesus
what are you doing providing so much
content we appreciate that thank you
thank you here we got Necromancer sale
two dollar Super Chat love these six
hour shows thank the Lord
is the gold standard for me on reviews
period yes thank God it's correct
definitely go stand everybody enjoy your
Sunday we will see you next week more
fun things planned we're out of here
peace out peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you